to taking this to Armageddon a oneoff
kind of shootout for the victory but
Maxim Vash gra I don't think he wants to
let it go that far it's been a while now
since the top players stopped
underestimating Dennis Dennis is just a
great player they all know that uh so
Maxim will need to bring his aame I
think he might try to hit Dennis in the
opening where still compared to hit the
slightly older players uh more
predictable but uh this one is anyone's
game I think it's a real 5050 Dennis
lazik is the super GM Slayer just to get
to the division W winners bracket he
beat Hikaru Nakamura and not just that
he took down Anish giri right after so
Dennis lavic he has what it takes
absolute monster just 17 years
old it's not about the size of the dog
in the fight it's about the size of the
fight in the dog and Dennis lasic has
made it clear he's not going to get
bullied he's going to bring on the fight
he's already relegated ma Hikaru
Nakamura and Anish gri can he do the
same against Maxim Vash gra today let's
take a look at the format of our
division one knockout stages it is a
double elimination bracket it's fast and
furious as the time control is just 10
minutes with a two second increment with
every move two and a half points gets
you the match victory in case of a tie
we will have the bidding Armageddon the
loser goes down to the losers bracket
the winner continues to stay on the top
in the winners bracket and the big thing
to remember in this season for all of us
is four events we will have eight
players to make it to the finals the
four winners from the four events and
from the tour standings the time format
changes we saw with 10 minutes and a two
second increment and for all the other
details about the changes in this year's
Champions chest you've got Danny
breaking it down for
us every Champions chess Tour event
kicks off with a playin tournament
followed by match play on the second day
to determine placement across divisions
1 2 and three the remaining players then
compete in these three divisions across
6 days of grueling yet thrilling double
elimination knockout chess all players
are battling to earn their chunk of the
$300,000 prize fund and Tour leaderboard
points but the biggest prize is a spot
directly to the live finals at the end
of the year only the winner of division
1 will claim that honor in addition they
and the runner up both secure re-entry
to the top division are next time around
the winner of division 2 also secur a
spot in division 1 while the winner of
division 3 is guaranteed at least a seat
in division 2 and may even advance to
division one through match play 8 days
three divisions one golden ticket to the
Champions chess Tour live finals this is
the chessel
[Music]
Masters the first golden ticket is up
for grabs in this one and the fight
starts in just a couple of minutes you
got four juc matchups and one of the
players who also made it to division one
Ali RZA fuja now he had a disappointing
Toronto finals he's definitely looking
for a better performance uh this year in
the Champions chess store what are we
expecting from alira and what did you
make of his performance in the
placements yeah I've for got to say
Alara I was quite impressed throughout
the placements it felt like uh okay he's
not quite in top form he's moving
through the gears but he was always
there or thereabouts and when the chips
were down when it mattered he made his
Mark and that's been the story of uh the
last 12 months for Razer up and down his
year his rating uh in tataa steal it was
up and down lots of wins but lots of
losses as well so it's entertaining for
us we're loving it as commentators but
he'll want a calmer progression of
course through these knockout rounds um
I want to see ala on his aame Happy Days
for Ali Raza because yesterday he
defeated vladislav artmia and we know
how dangerous artm can be and so can his
opponent Vladimir foso I don't think
that anyone wants to face the big fish
because he's taken down the likes of the
very best players on the planet this is
a pretty epic
Clash the big fish in division one sorry
David I'm I'm just loving those
fashionable and victorious big fish in a
big pond uh these players just loving
those nicknames and I wanted to ask you
guys we now know the eight uh eight
finalists I'm going to say in division
one who in division one do you think is
going to take that golden
ticket putting you on the
spot tell I'm waiting for
you gosh it's hard to bet against this
guy called Magnus Carlson you know I
mean I don't know if you guys have heard
about him if you know him I mean he is
uh the he won three events in Champions
chesta 2023 he is the three-time under
ring tour Champion he is the world
number one he's always eating on camera
it always looks like he's just woken up
his hair is all over the place but his
chest oh my God always on point it
certainly is and look at Magnus right
now as you said it it does seem like he
may have just woken up he's wearing a
pretty fashionable shirt and we'll see
if his chest is up to par with how he
has played in the past because I think
David's point from earlier is a very
good one that even for Magnus he can be
a bit slow to wake up on the chess board
it sometimes takes a few games to get
your feet beneath you so for Magnus you
don't have the luxury of time when
you're playing Wesley so because if
Wesley can win the first game it's
really hard to beat that guy he is one
of the most solid players in the planet
yeah and I do know that Magnus has more
tournaments lined up his next tournament
is Fisher random freestyle chess I know
he's been focusing on that a lot so this
might be the time to strike him when his
attention has strayed perhaps when he's
not quite warmed up yet and uh yeah of
course Magnus he's going to be the
favorite good choice Tanya but I think
we might see a surprise at least on this
this first
day well when you play Super Grand
Masters you better be warmed up and we
were mentioning how Dennis lazic he beat
Hikaru and an Niche yesterday just to
make it to division one look at how
underrated this kid is I call him Dennis
the Menace and for good reason because
his rating may be 2550 at least on paper
but look at these results on a world
class stage in the world rapid in 2022
2667 performance then the world Blitz
right after that
276 4 in the 2023 World rapid 2621 the
2023 World Blitz 2693 he is performing
over 2700 in the quickest of time
controls and of course in the CCT finals
in Toronto he didn't make it through but
he beat Maxim Basher lra head-to-head
still perform about 2650 so it is very
clear that his ratings should be thrown
out the window because he is always
overperforming his ratings have not
caught up to his strength you relegate
hiar Nakamura you relegate Anish giri
everyone's taking you seriously in this
event danis lavic was so impressive in
last season and we often spoke about his
style of play which is so different from
his colleagues and his contemporaries
from The Young under 20 generation right
now we see him play these strategic
positions we see him fight it out duel
it out in these long end games he
manages to hold against the very best
when he gets that opportunity he strikes
in it he has that patience and that's
what makes him so different David what
do you think is the reason we see him go
in the long run against the very best in
the world is it the style of play that
we've been talking about yeah Dennis
Lazar Vicious he's uh just he's got this
confidence that uh kind of belies his
young age he yeah he really kind of
believes in his ability to handle these
end games these long grinds and his
opening repertoire so finely honed
everything you need in Rapid chess in
speed chess Dennis lavic has it nerves
of Steel fantastic openings and uh that
confidence to pounce when even the best
players in the world are facing him uh
any small mistake he's ready to strike
so the only question is whether Dennis
will be lazza victorious in his uh in
his Clash today but in the meantime we
see Wesley so getting ready for that
match against mnus Carson so many games
and we'll try to follow them all and I
think Wesley so is walking around right
now in his playing room trying to figure
out where to put that second fair play
camera we saw him moving around with his
laptop and that he is still confused
about how to make the logistics work I
have to say I was following the the
placement action and Wesley situation
with the two chairs his laptop on uh one
of the chairs it was surprising to say
the least but it didn't it did not
affect his Chess at all well a part of
the fair play monitoring is showing that
there's no one else in your room that
everything is under control and when we
had Wesley so on camera there I saw in
the background he had like a rook and a
night on the shelf and there's Wesley
he's got a blanket he's he's not just
warmed up from yesterday's action but he
is warm and ready because he's under the
comfort of that security blanket so for
Wesley so he looks like he's ready to
play but as we saw behind him there's a
knight there's a rook and maybe he's the
king after
all Wesley looks warm he needs to get
the hot chess going against Magnus
Carlson you mentioned that he looks
secure in that blanket just mentioned a
really interesting thing David after
that victory in Toronto uh that he sort
of plays against Wesley style sort of
the lack of aggression in Wesley and is
Wesley bobbing to some music some tunes
there yeah Wes are we gonna see more
aggression Wesley had something in his
ears maybe it doesn't sound like the
most aggressive of Music uh the most
upbeat Tunes there it looks like a calm
slow Melody he looks very chilled so
chilled wesle so there but in the me me
time I agree he has to be aggressive on
the chessboard he has to uh kind of
knock back down not let Magnus dictate
the pace the nature the style of the
game and not let Magnus bully him
psychologically which uh you know we've
seen so many times from the world number
one Magnus lives rentree in most of our
heads he just has to ensure Wesley that
that doesn't happen today uh but we're
almost at game time we're almost off
we're awaiting the first moves Magnus
starts with white any predictions with
the opening before it's too late oh it
looks like the Rey he got that
first yeah we didn't have a chance to
put in our guesses but I think Magnus
then the lights are out at least over
his face so he needs to work on that
camera angle but hopefully the lights
are on upstairs in his head oh and there
we go he takes that drink of water and
what do you make of the opening Tanya
where Magnus he hasn't decided to create
tension the center at least not yet do
you like this sort of Cy start from him
well we see him do this quite often but
against Wesley it's usually been the
start with the King spawn open or the
Queen spawn opening at least that's what
we saw traditionally in the Champions
chest so a new approach but with Wesley
Speed that he's responded with he
doesn't look or at least he's not acting
to be too surprised with this and now
it's the big decision how does Wesley
keep the tension in the center here
robit well he decides instead of to keep
the tension he is trying to avoid it for
now David Magnus strikes with B4 so he
is trying to Chisel at Black's Pawn
chain and it is a pawn sacrifice what do
you make of this mini Gambit
yeah um I've got to say I like it but I
also hate it firstly you're a porn down
so not the not my cup of tea not the uh
kind of favorite approach by many top
players these days you don't want to be
too uh kind of materialistic in general
but here Magnus his idea was to open up
as many lines as possible and Robert you
mentioned it's kind of a flank Gambit
it's basically a reversed version of the
Beno Gambit as we call it but Wesley has
said no he bypassed this porn if Wy
earlier had captured on the A3 Square
then White's Rook would have opened up
on the a file there would have been open
lines here for the white Rook White's
Bishop would have come out so
interesting that Wesley could have been
a pawn up he did he is temporarily but
this Pawn will soon fall and uh I don't
know have you either of you two got
experience in the Beno Gambit I must say
not my era of
expertise no I've actually played this
position with the white pieces where
white pushes the B5 bar from B5 to B6
and gives that Bond back but again to me
this feels like a kg approach from
Wesley trying to keep things secure like
his blanket that he's got on right now
but then again this is the kind of stuff
that can backfire against Magnus Rob but
does this surprise you that Wesley
decided not to capture that A3 Pawn well
this entire opening has surprised me and
even magnus's last move pushing his Pawn
to A4 rather than recapturing on B3 both
sides are trying to lay claim to
important space and squares the B4 Four
Square for black is now firmly under
control and then for white you have this
light Square diagonal the bishop on G2
is unopposed on that diagonal and so we
could see that Bishop shining its powers
across the board I don't know whose
position I'd rather have it's a new
position to my eyes but it feels like
one where both players are on their own
yeah it feels like both players have
Trump cards uh up their sleeve uh you
mentioned the B4 Square wh night also
has access to a beautiful outpost on B5
a bit later first Magnus wins the porn
back and uh Tanya from your experience
you mentioned you've kind of played this
opening just with reverse colors um do
you think Magnus is going to be happy
here he's basically played an opening
you usually see with black but he's
white so he's got an extra Tempo should
he be happy about that and it's always
tricky to kind of adjust yourself to
these reverse colors opening one of the
ideas as white that I like in this and
that would mean a position that black
has currently for Wesley is to actually
transfer that knight from F6 to the C5
Square we've been talking about about
how important these squares are so
there's often this plan of the Knight
falling back and then finding itself on
C5 which is a nice Square I think Magnus
he was perhaps expecting a more Dynamic
approach by Wesley to capture that A3
Pawn to pick up that Fe Free Pawn which
gives a lot of activity to White uh and
now he has to fight in this position I
like these positions uh well in this
case for white uh sorry for for black
here simply because that knight from F6
will land on the square of C5 which is a
nice square and I'm getting confused as
a commentator with reverse colors I have
no idea how the players are handling it
and I I actually found that funny
because I'm doing the same thing in my
head because he is a b Gambit colors
revers and we saw for a quick moment
this bishop B4 move from Wesley perhaps
the most natural move developing your
piece getting ready to Castle putting on
defended Square the engine didn't really
approve it and I think it's precisely
because of what Magnus is doing he can
challenge this bishop immediately and if
white takes on B4 next move that Knight
on C6 could not capture back which is
why why Wesley right now brings his
Knight back to D7 that way the E5 Pawn
is well protected and if a capture on B4
happens he can successfully take back
with a knight rather than doubling his
pawns which you may want to do in some
positions but here I'm not so
sure yeah it feels like this is the two
players just tiptoeing around each other
Magnus makes that decision he trades off
the Bishops and uh yeah it's just a
fight for squares it's about maneuvering
and um I've got to say it feels like
traditionally this would favor Magnus
Carlson he's so good strategically so
good at kind of sensing where the
important squares are when to switch up
uh the pace the quickness of the game
but uh Wesley he's done nothing wrong
and evaluation bar slightly preferring
black I've got to agree just we're kind
of playing by association with colors
reversed yes Wesley's a Tempo down on a
known opening but he's got everything
covered Tanya your dream Square on C5
that night's going to be beautiful on
this Square feels like Magnus is taking
some big risks early on in this game and
evaluation But continuing to drop after
magnus's Retreat there white knight
wants to come around and stack on this
Pawn but he's not going to get time
surely Magnus uh Tanya are you agreeing
to my eyes it looks fantastic for black
yeah everything that you pointed at and
I also really like that Wesley captured
on B4 with that pawn on A5 at first it
looks like you're spoiling your Pawn
structure you're doubling up but you're
taking away some key squares from that
Knight on B1 well now the positions
change White had to spend some time
picking up that pawn and B4 and we see
the Queens are going to get traded off
because the A4 Pawn is is really weak
and just coming back to Robert's Point
earlier about this being a revers b
Gambit and extra Tempo that matters I
think Wesley's approach to go with the
move B4 to B3 early on in the game to
not go for the the picking up of the
Pawn in these kind of positions perhaps
the extra Tempo doesn't matter as much
it doesn't and it's because it's a
relatively closed position so I'm with
you Tanya and Wesley just quickly played
Queen to A5 he released the tension I
think he's going into this game with the
Mantra I'm going to try to draw with the
black pieces and then press with white
because he could have kept his B4 Pawn I
actually think that keeping more pieces
on the board was favorable for black
because White's pieces were stepping on
each other's toes somewhat now after the
queen trade Mass Liquidation on the a
file the A4 Pawn is dropping I don't
think that black is any worse at the
moment that's for sure but I don't know
if there's so many winning chances left
because there aren't that many pieces
remaining oh and some of these moves uh
in the game review here not uh proved of
by the computer this was a missed
opportunity for Wesley so to my eyes it
looks like a very natural move he's
trying to gain time now against this
white Rook actually if the Queens
disappear I wouldn't be surprised uh for
example on the next move if the black
king uh just shifts to D7 swings the
other Rook across and if the Queens are
off the board Black's pieces are so
actively placed wesle so at least in my
eyes turning things in his favor I think
Magnus really needs to kind of pull the
break shift gears here and try to make
that draw Wesley on the camera smiling
as well uh he looks thrilled with his
position and rightly so I wish we could
see how Magnus is feeling that dark
shadow uh there we go brightening up
Suddenly but I don't think his mood is
feeling very bright with this position
here after the Queens leaving the board
now it's all about how active Black's
pieces are like Robert said earlier this
Pawn is doomed sooner or later Wesley
can of take it at his leisure and
nothing at all to worry about here for
black it's just about whether he can try
to turn it into an advantage even at
some point
and now the big question is David has
Wesley red grind like a grandm because
it looks like it might be time to start
thinking about that an end game you got
peace activity the A4 Pawn is about to
fall Black's King in the center is
actually ideally play because you don't
even need to go Shar Castle anymore you
could go with your king to D7 as Wesley
does it bring the other Rook into play
I'm loving Wesley's position right now I
love the way Wesley's handling this
because that pawn A4 is not going
anywhere it cannot legally move and it
cannot be defended very easily so black
wants to set up the second Rook over to
A8 to keep control of this open file or
put a rook on B8 and then slam it down
on B2 so that's why Magnus realizing he
doesn't have all the time in the world
to just sit and see this Rook get active
he decides to strike in the center with
Pawn to F4 and if the black pawn E5 is
removed D4 is loose so these are some
difficult decisions for Wesley he might
just push his Pawn to F6 to keep a nice
Pawn chain everything defended but you
see Wesley investing some time right now
because there may be tactics with that
black king on D7 it's still in the
center of the board there's still Rooks
uh on the the position here so I think
Wesley he's just trying to be accurate
what Magnus shook his head he's not
happy black is certainly no
worse as you predict Robert there black
does play Pawn to F6 we see a quick
trade and Magnus activates his knight uh
this game looks like it's roughly in the
balance but perhaps Magnus here needing
to be uh slightly more careful than
Wesley uh just to
that uh kind of equal position maybe
it's time to jump over to check out
another game we'll update everyone of
course on these developments I want to
check out the other game we've been
talking about a lot Maxim vasra against
Dennis lazeric and we jump in at a
moment where again a small cross a
missed opportunity for black natural to
me and level material in this one what
are your first instincts about this
position how should we evaluate it well
I'm just we come in and there
immediately a Miss Right giving an X and
normally you would say that the black's
position looks quite solid to my eyes
the bishop on B2 for white it's not
playing the Knight on H4 where is it
going so perhaps black has something a
little bit stronger but the position
looks very sturdy from Dennis lack's
perspective I think he's handled this
opening perfectly he is not worse in the
slightest and I don't know where white
even hopes to build an advantage
from Tanya um are you uh kind of
favoring either side here looks like
maybe denn Dennis has escaped the
opening in good shape here I think both
the games that we've checked out black
is doing great in this one danis in the
earlier one Wesley they've gotten out of
the opening without too much trouble
this one is so symmetrical the pond
structure the minor piece balance
everything no such weaknesses that last
move by Dennis C6 taking control of that
Central D5 Square making sure that white
doesn't have any jumps with that Knight
on E5 anymore so Maxim decides to
improve the position of that other
Knight that you were pointing out Knight
coming back to F3 but I'm still not
seeing how white actually makes progress
you can't really push the C Pawn because
the B4 Pawn will be hanging there so the
B2 Bishop still struggles to come into
the game I agree with both of you that
for Dennis this has been a good
start great start for Dennis lazic and
this one it does feel like the Calm
before the storm uh long long way to go
we look at the clock times with our new
time control this season season both
players still with plenty of time left
and two second increment to boot Max
slightly ahead on the clock there but I
think we should go back to that Marquee
game uh to Magnus Carson against Wesley
so because that one feels like it's
racing towards a conclusion and uh yeah
we're deep into the end game
now he's got a set of Rooks off the
board but visually it looks so
attractive uh my eyes at least for black
Black's King more active in the center
than wh it can choose which direction to
go later Black's Bishop keeping the
white king uh feeling a bit
uncomfortable for now and at the right
moment you still can take enough umt do
you think Magnus here has he kind of
survived the worst or can Wesley
continue to be ambitious he jumps in
with a knight wow and he forced that
Rook to a whoa what's he pre-moving
Knight to C1 I mean if the Rook went to
A2 Knight C1 would have picked up the E2
Pawn but Wesley trying to get that one
anyway and look at this exclamation
point given to Bishop to G4 uh he's
trying to provoke this E Pawn to push
because a pawn chain is only as strong
as its base pawn and so the E2 D3 C4
Pawn chain look nice and steady
everything well defended but if you have
to push up to E3 then that pawn on E uh
D3 becomes a Target Bishop D1 becomes
available and then Knight on C2 is in
some trouble the A4 Pawn remains loose
so White's pieces are awkwardly placed I
actually you know at first like what's
Wesley doing pre-moving but he's that
strong at even bullet chess that he
understands the position and the
Dynamics seem to be favoring
black oh look at this Magnus just
ignores the threat what's his idea this
Pawn is simply falling and Wesley
gobbles it up he's trying to undermine
the Black Knight now but Wesley he's
destroyed that pawn chain you were
talking about Robert this is a peace
sacrifice he's given up his Knight and
uh I'm assuming it's going to be
captured what else then black will take
the A4 pawn and he's going to bank on
these two connected passes in the center
to just race down the ball Bo is this
genius is this Magnus Magnus I was to
say was it a bit of both Wesley to try
and win this
game I love it I love this approach by
Wesley Magnus said his strategy against
Wesley is about hustling him hustling
Wesley's lack of aggression we've seen
none of that Wesley's going all out he
delays the picking up of the a pawn he
first picks up the Central Pawn and now
he sacrificed an entire piece but we've
got to do a deep dive into this position
because for moment Wesley's down a night
in the position you're pointing out the
E Pawn also the black Rook jumping onto
that second rank with a ton of pinning
ideas with retu coming up how much
trouble is this I see the evalar says
it's still even but from a practical
perspective is Magnus feeling the heat
right now I think he is I mean this
position looks uncomfortable for white
because the Knight on C2 is already
threatened by the bishop as you
mentioned Tanya Rook A2 becomes an
immediate threat and let's say you want
to jump your Knights forward somewhere
Knight F3 is met by the simple King to
D6 improving the location of the black
king because you're defending you're
loose Pawn the king is active used as a
weapon in the end game so I'm looking at
this position and Magnus needs to be
very careful here because if he makes a
single mistake it's no longer a balanced
game that's completely in Wesley's
favor guys I want to make you guess the
best move I took a peak I thought
White's position is so ugly here so
unattractive how does Magnus hold this
together what do you think White's best
move is
it's unfindable for a human that's a big
clue uh I'm gonna just I
think1 yeah I was gonna actually say
Knight A1 because the way you ask the
question is so leading and it's not a
natural move at all but if anyone on
this planet can find it I think it's
Magnus Carlson wow look at him shifting
in his chair there Magnus leaning
forward he knows this is a key position
uh I was attracted to your King E1 there
Tanya as well I think a very logical
move but in the end after a move like
Pawn to C5 Whit's Knights are just stuck
pretty much Z swanked but Knight A1 is
the best move according to the computer
the idea is to loop around this Knight
to rotate it round to B3 and uh the
knights Superfluous knights we sometimes
call them but they cling on to each
other for example if the black Rook
drops down Knight to B3 and for now
you're holding but this is so hard to
evaluate I mean to my eyes it looks like
black plays Robert's move King D6 the
pawns are rolling running but after King
to F3 you have a semi blockade on kind
of some important squares and the
knight's surviving but Magnus needs to
find this move and I think it's almost
impossible Knight to A1 he plays Knight
F3 instead and now Roberts mve King D6
looks like it gives black a big
Advantage black moving forward in
control question mark given to that move
we can't fault it very human Knight F3
especially in Rapid chess who's going to
look at a move like Knight A1 and Magnus
gives his piece back this is going to be
oneway traffic now level material yet
again but at the right moment you can
take this Pawn not yet because there
might be some night Forks some KN checks
so maybe Wesley takes some time out to
guard against that but uh yeah feels
like Magnus in big big trouble in game
one today well Tanya I was about to ask
you that Magnus up a piece for two pawns
but those pawns were running up the
board restricting wh's pieces do you
think this is a good practical try for
Magnus because at least what he could
Envision for a draw blockade in the dark
squares trying to take away some of
these remaining black ponds do you think
the draw seems more Within Reach now I
think Knight A1 the move that you were
discussing and Robert that you pointed
out is so difficult to play and to even
find it's not even on your radar a
retreating move all the way back to A1
you're not sure how you're coming out of
the fix that you're in so you really
want to try and simplify the position I
think you're on point Magnus just wants
to get out of this game he wants to find
the fastest way to neutralize but this
might not be neutralizing at all because
a bishop will versus knight in these end
games is good news for black you can try
and push you have to watch out for that
Knight on G7 getting trapped Bishop to
F7 it comes back how are you retreating
with the Knight if the minor pieces get
traded off this is winning for black are
you going G4 King F5 a knight F5 I'm
sorry process of elimination you have to
play G4 this is the only route back for
the White Knight but Wesley has cut off
this Square F5 now taken away uh from
the White Knight and big threat the
knight's still trapped like you say
Tanya if there's a trade Knight for
Bishop black will win due to this
distraction the outside pass Pawn so
Magnus now needs to keep his Knight
alive is it the move G5 just to stop the
threat but this is still incredibly ugly
you're playing without a piece and
Black's Pawn looks like it's racing down
the board he plays it again process of
elimination but is he going to save this
game exclamation mark only move there
from Magnus he's surviving by the skin
of his teeth Robert do you see any
resources can black continue pushing
well White now wants to do is play H4 H5
and G6 just get rid of that H7 Pawn
because if that pawn is no longer on the
board then the white pieces will go
march on over to the C Pawn either
blockade it or sacrifice the Knight for
that last Pawn a lone King and Bishop
cannot deliver Checkmate for those of
you who are newer in the audience so
that is what white is aiming for get all
of Black's pawns off the board even if
you have to sacrifice your knight in the
process a great move G5 H4 comes next
the black king kind of has to stay put
because as it goes up to F4 Knight can
now slide back to E6 for check and the
Knight is safe yeah Magnus should be
saving this game now that the White
Knight escapes that dungeon on G7 uh
let's take a zoom out of this one very
briefly uh just to check in on the other
action Magnus does play the best move
gets his Knight out of Dodge there and
this is the bird's eye view we see the
evaluation bars mostly roughly around
the center um Vash gra against lavic has
been level since we left it not much to
report there apart from maybe lazic
knight uh on the top left of your
screens in the top left corner as well
the other games NPI on the back foot
against man of the moment Jose Martinez
Magnus should draw now against wo and
fev against fua also roughly balanced um
what catches your eye here Robert from
the other games I think that Jose
Martinez game with the black pieces
against two-time World Championship
Challenger Yan naom because Jose
celebrated his birthday a couple days
ago when he won came in first place in
the playin then he was able to sail
through the placement and now here he is
in division one so the recent birthday
boy look at that last move by the way G5
allowing a fork with check on F6 but you
sometimes need to protect your King by
getting active on the side that you're
being attacked because now that pawn on
G5 is well defended by another Pawn on
H6 its best friend whereas the pawn on
G7 that was well within White's
attacking range and queen takes H6 was
on the docket so I love moves like this
and I love the way that Jose plays chess
even though he's down to 22 seconds
remaining this is super complex and uh
Jos bam his birthday week seems like
it's continuing and Yan napam nushi
doesn't go to pick up that exchange on
E8 because at night on H5 it's such a
key piece for white Yan it's very
important for him to try to create the
initiative he's down in exchange
currently but practically still a lot of
Chances with black king being so weak
and just 20 seconds to defend this
position it feels like it's all about
the clock uh I'm used to seeing uh Jose
here just hustle his opponents whenever
I play him on chess.com he's always
flagging me you know he's so quick so
instinctive but yeah npish she has to
use this clock situation against black
now I'm not sure whether you jump in
with your knight and kind of again hint
that you might go for this Rook which is
almost trapped or do you at some point
push a pawn forward try to break this uh
kind of stronghold on G5 with your pawns
but the white Rook as well lacking
squares this is not easy White's queen
super passive this is why White's attack
is not that dangerous and evaluation bar
I think to be trusted in this type of
position um it's so wild it's so chaotic
sometimes we say don't trust the bar
it's a very human position but feels
like Jose has ridden the storm and uh
wow Pawn to H4 I was reluctant to
suggest it immediately maybe a bit later
because suddenly this Rook lacking
squares and instead he jumps in with the
Black
Knight wow what a move yeah he's
defending by attacking he's just trying
to remove all of White's most aggressive
pieces if the knights come off the board
The Rook takes on D4 so look at whoa y
goes Knight takes G5 and Jose jumps in
with his Knight because the D2 Bishop is
loose and the Queen on C1 is under
attack everything's hanging for white
which piece do you save there's three up
for grab's next move you've got to check
but the black king can simply run you G5
I'm just looking at all the checks David
you're pointing out the king running E7
is the only square is Bishop G5
something that you can start looking at
already
I think you have to Tanya I think you're
completely right this Bishop's dropping
anyway you might as well sell it for a
high price you can get check and he goes
for the check you get your queen out of
the way as well but black is a rook up
black has a whole extra Rook yes uh the
white Knights can fork and win back some
material but the black king if it gets
over to B8 this is game over black is
too much material two more moves and
Jose Martinez is going to get this
Victory 12 seconds what do you think
Robert is this going to be enough I
think it that josam has the clear Edge
that's what Jose is known as his
username and it's the petan King march
and look at that Rook takes Knight on E8
apparently wasn't the best move it's
impossible not to play that when someone
takes your piece you want to capture
back and I think the one thing keeping
white potentially in this game is that
H4 Pawn it's not a shield for the white
king it's a passer that you want to push
wow wow he's so good double exclamation
mark that last move dropping a bomb on
the position Queen to G1 check with will
lead to Checkmate it's that famous combo
the queen and Knight teaming up at this
point it's pretty much against the lone
King and oo it's the Petrosian King
march you mentioned Robert this time
it's the white king that's running up
the board both Kings have been doing a
bit of dancing here but the white king
is doomed no way to escape if you step
forwards F5 there's going to be a deadly
check on F3 and white has to lose even
more material Yom she smiles and he's
about to
resign wow this is it's almost and he
does it and Jin reacts he gets the dub
he wins the first game against Yan the
birthday gifts keep coming oh yes and
wow what a game that was Knight D4
checkmate with so many pieces smothering
the white king so what a final touch
from josam from Jose Martinez and you
saw how much it meant him David he gave
us that fist pump in celebration yeah
and there's action happening elsewhere
there was a draw in the meantime between
Wesley so and Magus Carson uh there's a
deep end game between laic and VRA but
this one's still going and 4 seconds on
the clock for fuja exclamation mark but
he's wow he's battling pawns both sides
have pawns running down the board this
black A2 Pawn close to touchdown and
white pawns soon running but uh Robert
help me out whose position is favorable
here evaluation Bar says level but this
one surely is anyone's game oh look at
that how quickly the tables turn but
Bishop E6 giving a check apparently not
the right followup so for both these
players it's good that they don't know
the evaluation as this position is
anyone's game it's extremely
messy oh it's messy but now the black
Rook is infiltrated this was so cunning
from fuja with only a few seconds left
this Bishop's trapped and black is on
the brink of making a new Queen uh black
luckily can give up his own Bishop to
stop White's f- Pawn if the white Pawn
ever pushes it's simply going to be
eliminated feels like black suddenly now
out of nowhere ahead in the race White's
King got active but in the end walks
into a dead end and uh here we go this
whole variation is playing out it's all
about the black a porn and FIA shutting
the door white porn dropping no more
counterplay Tanya what do you think is
this just going to be over now yeah I
think it's uh it's quite beautifully
played the last couple of moves by Ala
fuja now there's nothing to be done as
you pointed out the E Pawn isn't moving
forward anymore and it's going to be the
a pawn that will decide the game looks
like Al RAR is about to take the first
win and meanwhile Wesley so Magnus
Carlson did end in a draw yeah and well
that game was a draw this one looks like
it's great for black but I caness he oh
he drops the a right away no time for
fua he saw Knight C2 coming and now it
should be a hold with best play but
should have would have Coulda this is
now speed chess and by the way rook and
Bishop versus Rook theoretically drawn
everybody but really hard to save when
you have no
time with seven seconds on the clock now
white needs to give up the night for
this black porn and Tred to hope to
defend that but this is going to be a
long fight ahead no certainty here and
fja he knows he was winning so might be
a bit of frustration in him uh White can
now give a check for example uh with the
white Rook but no okay the Pawn's
marching the White Knight is a bit
offside and the bar disappears this
check and wh's pieces are just too far
away they're not going to stop this
black porn from racing down the board
it's going to Sprint towards touchdown
on
C1 better to say if he just rushed a bit
too much 25 seconds he didn't coordinate
his pieces and look how the bishop
totally dominates this Knight the bishop
on this diagonal just cutting across the
white Knights Retreats
and well see a result now he surely
isn't going to let this one slip ala
fuia you've been talking about the
defensive technique of sacrificing that
Knight for the C3 Pawn that Knight isn't
going to get to the C3 Pawn no it's
because oliv understood the assignment
he knew what white was going for and he
said I'm not going to allow it and now
the king can just March forward helped
that pawn escor it to the other side and
then Knight on D7 it needs to be back in
White's territory it's way too far away
Knight's being slow moving pieces not
helping oh and he's going to use the
bishop as a blockader the black Bishop's
going to come in uh to help the pawn
promote on C1 or The Bishop's going to
help block some checks there we go
Bishop to F2 shuts the door in fed's
face and black makes a new Queen it's a
matter of time now it looks like they'
swapped sides Black's pieces are
starting on White's starting row but a
check double attack game over fuja takes
the win the first game of the
day ala fuja convert but he was winning
earlier on he messed it up FV had his
chance but in the end manages to get
fev's night out of the game a brilliant
conversion there David that means we
have finished our round one games some
interesting results there uh Robert what
what surprised you the most about this
one well the players winning with the
black pieces that's not something that
we can say all the time although in tata
Steel in the classical chest it seemed
like in the opening rounds that was the
norm but for Jose Martinez and their Ali
Za fua huge wins with the black pieces
yeah and there we have our game one from
the winners quarterfinals it is a best
of four two and a half points takes the
match and it is Jose Martinez and alira
fuja who take the lead in their match
the other two matches start with draw
Dennis lazic with a confident hold
against Maxim V grab Wesley saw in
driver's seat with the black pieces and
another confident hold against uh Magnus
Carlson who was on the defense but got
the job
done what a first round to start the day
Magnus living life on the edge surviving
by the skin of his teeth and those two
black winds definitely the highlights
fuja it was in the balance for so long
but he turned on the magic when it was
necessary deep in the end game but
Martin
I've got to say Robert just looks like
the man in form right now in this rapid
form out in 10 minutes on the clock for
him it's plenty he's just crushing the
best players in the world well for Jose
he doesn't get to play that much over
theboard chess but he thrives online he
plays in every single title Tuesday he's
a streamer a content creator and
somebody who lives for the moment and he
lives for that time pressure because
he's always in with minimal time on his
clock those few seconds that's when he
actually brings out his best I mean way
just checkmated y nishi's King in those
final few moves getting the queen on the
back rank Queen G1 Queen H1 just
absolute precision and that checkmate
with the Knight on that Central Square
that's going to be a tough one for Yanna
pishi to get out of but he needs to do
that Yan starts with the black pieces in
the next one but also equally impressive
Dennis lavic against Maxim
VRA didn't get to cover that game too
much it was just very level throughout
Dennis he's so good at keeping control
and uh just justifies his billing as the
underdog gets that draw great result for
young Dennis in the meantime looks like
we're jumping straight back into the
action we're awaiting Wesley so's return
to his laptop screen to that chair that
setup whatever we're going to call it
Wesley getting ready to fight I've got
to say guys I love what he did in game
one he just needs to do it all over
again in game two uh just with
Magnus and I was just about to say are
we going to see a 1 B3 an opening that
Wesley so played in The Grand Final in
the season tour Final in 2023 against
Magnus Carlson but we are not seeing any
of that he starts with the queen Pawn
opening and wow Magnus going are we
going to see a Kings Indian by Magnus in
this one oh well it depends yeah yeah I
was going to say it depends what kind of
mood he was in but David you saw it
before I could even respond do you see
Wesley by the way he's like bringing up
his blanket making sure that it's
sitting nicely on his lap as we are
going to Venture into one of the most
aggressive openings from the black side
if Wesley allows to happen because you
can take this into quieter Waters if he
so
chooses uh the king's Indian defense
Magnus only really plays it when he's
all out for blood for victory um I very
rarely see Magnus employ this defense
when he's happy to just kind of keep
things solid when he just wants to kind
of grind it out in an long end game this
one uh only in the biggest of occasions
in must-win situations with black
usually so it's a big sign
from Magnus to Wesley saying yes you got
you got close in round one but now I'm
going to fight fire with fire and I'm
going to come back at you and Robert you
mentioned taking the game into quieter
Waters I don't want to see Wesley for
example trade off Pawns in the center
here I don't want to see him trade off
and get the Queens off the board which
he has done in the past on occasion no
he castles keeping all the tension and
uh yeah this one's shaping up nicely
Mainline Kings Indian all these romantic
openings these attacking openings
they're coming back into fashion which
we love to see some Kings gambits in
tata steel and now in the Champions
chest the uh Kings Indian instead and
Magnus just choosing the way he's going
to set up Knight to D7 Knight to C6
taking on D4 Magnus is played on
occasion H6 is the trendy move here uh
all the cool kids are playing I don't
understand it but plenty of choice
Magnus the first app
pause and for Magnus Carlson as you said
he doesn't really play this that often
and you look to the left of the board
that shows the statistics when this
opening is play played in Master Level
games so Wesley so you know he knows
that this opening should be good for
white in fact the engines they love it
because they like the extra space that
white gets especially if he push this
Pawn from D4 up to D5 but by releasing
the tension if white in fact does push
this Pawn black will move the Knight
away from F6 and play F5 himself opening
up the king side so Wesley he knows that
the computer is a fan of this from the
white side he has experience but he also
has experience playing Hikaru Nakamura
who crushed him in one game because this
opening can be vicious from the black
side depending on how white tries to
adopt the
setup and white needs to now decide it
is that moment because with magnus's
last move eyeing that Knight on F3
there's more pressure on that Central D4
Pawn so finally Wesley has to take a
call he either captures on E5 or blocks
the center with the move D5 uh David is
there a third option to try to keep the
tension going
here perhaps the third option would be
to use the bishop and guard this square
but I favor your choices there Tanya
depending on Wesley's mood uh I think
the most ambitious if Wesley's up for a
fight okay he actually plays the third
choice there Bishop to E3 I was going to
say he could push his Pawn forward a the
computer is such a harsh critic giving
that move a question mark but he could
also have taken the pawn off on E5 and
there would have been a bunch of
exchanges uh so Bishop to E3 Let's
ignore that question mark for now I
think this time we'll give Wesley the
benefit of the doubt but uh this is
perhaps not approved of by computers
because after a trade on F3 Magnus I
think that would be the consistent
followup he goes for it now after a
trade he's going to bring his Knight out
and this bishop uh a bit similar to
Robert pointing out in the previous game
Magnus is Bishop on the long diagonal
this is going to be the MVP most
valuable piece and Magnus yeah I think
he's he's going to be happy dark Square
bind White's Bishop on F3 is just
blocked in staring at its own pawns so I
like what Magnus has done Wesley not the
most ambitious way of fighting against
the Kings Indian but this is ambitious
from the black side there's a famous
game maybe the stem game of this
variation voic versus Fabiano Carana
where Fabiano Play Bishop on G7 takes
Knight on C3 that seems Unthinkable to
our chess Learners out there you're
giving away the bishop that helps
protect the dark squares in front of
your king whenever you're fing ketto you
typically want your Bishop to sit there
because it stares across the diagonal
and protect squares like H6 and F6 down
the line so your opponent cannot invade
but Bishop takes C3 has a clear point
that with Rook E8 the Black Knight is
stepping forward to E5 and C5 that
White's pawns they do well to take care
of critical squares but they're also
extended quite far and thus vulnerable
so these are big decisions for both
players and I think that they have that
stem game the voic Carana game in their
mind and I think this last move by
Wesley goes against that plan that you
were pointing out because if black was
to capture on C3 now you can take with
the queen you don't really compromise on
the pawn structure and you get all the
advantages of the bishop pair meanwhile
David I think white is also threatening
to move Bishop to 86 to my understanding
black shouldn't trade the pair of
Bishops in these position how can Magnus
avoid these further trades here I love
it Tanya thinking about what the
opponent wants the opponent might want
to just get rid of this sniper on G7 uh
this Archer from afar so by playing a
move such as Rook to E8 here um I'll
just put this on the board Rook to E8
now suddenly black would be free to
decide what to to do with this bishop
yes you can still trade them off but you
also have the added option of Simply
dropping back keeping the bishop on the
long diagonal and saying to White
actually your Bishop looks pretty but
it's not doing anything on H6 and uh if
we go back to the game wow he's just
taking it off immediately Robert The
Profit just take that piece W they tell
you to study your Classics I know that a
game from a few years ago isn't
considered a classic cuz not enough time
has gone by but Fabiano Carana teaches
not just us but Magnus Carl in a very
important and intive lesson that
sometimes it is okay to say you know to
heck with the rules the principles that
I learned sometimes we can throw them
out the window if the position calls for
it and look at this queen of six Queen
trade being offered we talk about the
bishop pair Advantage here it's the
knights that are going to do some damage
because they can stare and hop over
pieces a knight on E5 you know hit a
bishop on F3 a Pawn on C4 a knight on F6
or C5 hits that pawn on e4 and if to
protect that pawn on e4 you have to move
your dark Square Bishop but it's as soon
as that Bishop leaves E3 a knight can
jump into D4 as well so many critical
squares are Black's Knights for the
taking I think Wesley has to be very
careful here it's not like the engine
hates his position but it does seem
easier to play from the black side
because the bishop on F3 in particular
it does not have a useful diagonal it's
staring into its own E4 pawn and if it
tries to move to a new diagonal it
stares into his own C4 Pawn no active
real estate for that
Bishop really instructive I'm going to
go uh check out that game uh for check
against kowana just to remind myself and
clearly Magnus has been studying fabby's
games there really kind of catching
Wesley off guard we see the clock
situation Magnus kind of a minute and a
half up on the clock could be important
for later but yeah just Breaking All the
Rules but you got to know the rules went
in order to figure out when to break
them and yeah these Knights I'm always
biased towards Bishops but uh on this
occasion I'll give Magnus the benefit of
the doubt they're jumping the knights
coming in uh yeah looks like Wesley the
one with questions to answer I think
this is the perfect moment to zoom out
uh maybe we go to the bird's eye view as
Magnus applies pressure to Wesley's
position and okay lots of different
types of games some more exciting than
others I've got to say uh where are your
eyes draw
Tanya it's the one on the extreme right
of our screen you got Ali RZA fuja
against fedos and the position is all
kinds of Bonkers White's got a queen out
on H4 the kings are in the center
there's a knight on B5 Black's spawn
already on D4 that's the position that
has gotten my attention um while
meanwhile we see the Central boards it's
pretty level between Wesley and Magnus
still let's do a deep dive into this one
yeah and uh normally we won't do this
this is fast Furious rapid chest but I'm
going to do a quick rewind to the start
of this game uh because it is crazy as
you mentioned Tanya so unorthodox so
irrational this position white is just
one a pawn but black wow okay we'll do a
very quick dive it started Life as a
kocan and uh
in in advanced variation it was Pawn to
C5 just blowing open the center and
after a capture White's Queen takes on
D4 and uh yeah let's catch up the White
Queen dancing it gets harassed so often
remember kids remember folks don't bring
your queen out too early she is the most
valuable piece anytime she gets hit she
has to move and let's show this tactic
on The Bard super cool Knight takes Pawn
now ignoring the Knight taking this one
instead if the Knight had been captured
then Queen to A5 is a well-known Fork a
double attack black regains the piece
with uh interest so uh Bishop to E2 the
reply from fuja and this is the game
position uh and okay a
check feels like it's calming down
slightly but uh still nice to see the
players kind of throwing out these crazy
creative moves early on well it seems
like the come before a potential second
storm because black has not developed
the kingside pieces you see the night on
G8 The Rook on h8 they're sitting at
home and this A2 Pawn is loose do not
get greedy prioritize your development
and to make sure your king is safe
because if you first swap Knights you
know so the Black Knight isn't hanging
on E5 and then you decide to take this
Pawn on A2 white is just going to Castle
the King give you that second Pawn on B2
and then go right after your king with
moves like Rook to E1 Rook to B1 the
engine actually says that this is okay
for black that is shocking to my eyes
because it does feel like with the black
king still in the center not casting
anytime soon you should just be hopeless
I think practically speaking there's no
way you survive but an engine it's the
best chess player on the planet for a
reason it's heartless it's cold blooded
and it says I can defend this even
though I have activated absolutely
nothing besides my
queen gonna say he's never ever going to
do this he's never going to try this and
of course he doesn't Knight to F6 he's
too well trained classically trained
there fed he gets his pieces out and
really instructive there Robert I
totally agree I don't think any
Grandmaster would seriously consider
getting that trigger happy that porn
hungry and uh start grabbing on A2 now
it's just time for black to get castled
do the same as white and level material
um which side do you favor here Tanya uh
whose side do you think is easier to
play just really slightly I like white
hair and I think that's because of the
piece activity and the placement of the
pieces without the dark Square Bishop on
G7 I think the black king will be
slightly vulnerable on the king side as
well also notice how white can line up
The Rook on E1 and start targeting that
E7 Pawn eventually once the knights on
the center of the board are traded off
the bishop whether it lands eventually
on F3 which I think it might now with
this Knight trade you could recapture
with Bishop takes Knight bring that Rook
to E1 just feel that White's pieces are
are more active and like you said David
easier to play and in this time format
that is the most critical
thing having won the first game of today
uh he can use that kind of uh to good
effect I feel like this type of position
he's pretty much provoking fed maybe on
the next move to go grabbing this Pawn I
said he would never do it on the last
move but at least now he's one move only
away from castling it feels slightly
kind of less risky to go for that PA now
but fuja yeah with that win uper sleeve
already draws not the worse result and
okay he takes with a knight instead uh
bit of a surprise the Knight looks
really beautiful in the center the white
Bishop now not happy about that decision
um but ultimately feels like black
should just get castled don't risk
taking this B
I don't even see a specific concrete
reason not to but it feels all wrong and
fed whoa he goes for
it way I am shocked that fedos have made
this decision but perhaps it's
influenced by the first game of the
match remember he did lose game one with
the white pieces when F was able to
Queen at the end so he's thinking it
might be now or never let's mix it up
but Bishop C4 I think this is why Ali
Ren took with the Knight rather than
with the bishop yes a bishop on F3
looked great great but here a bishop on
C4 hits the queen on A2 and the pawn on
F7 and if you continue to be Pawn hungry
and you grab this Pawn on B2 I think you
can move your Rook to E1 but the C1 Rook
it's counterintuitive but if you move
the E F1 Rook Instead The Rook on C1 was
loose in many of the resulting positions
but if you slide the uh C1 Rook away as
you show Castle Rook takes E7 is no
longer possible but with a rook on F1
safely tucked away you can successfully
grab this Pawn in the seventh rank so
just try to Envision that in these
positions there could have been a rook
on C1 which would have made this line
impossible now instead of leaving The
Rook on C1 That's The Rook that steals
the pawn on the seventh rank yeah I just
want to go one move further one move
deeper black can steal a third Pawn he's
said a b he might as well say C and take
the C Pawn but white will at the very
minimum start doubling up stacking up
the Rooks and it feels like there's
going to be all sorts of trouble Black's
Queen remember has to guard this Knight
otherwise Queen takes Knight using the E
file pin already all sorts of taxit in
the air um I'm looking at the White
Knight leaping forward to hit the F7
Pawn maybe even sacrifices on this
Square in the near future Black's King
will not survive this storm uh so if we
go back to the game position I think
fuja he's just got to go for it provoke
this second Pawn capture Bishop to C4
initiative blade momentum at every move
with a threat and white builds up this
phenomenal phenomenal attack he doesn't
see the evaluation bar of course he
doesn't even play Bishop C4 but uh now
at least fed can get castled he's trying
to transpose into that variation Robert
but you mentioned it the wrong Rook
White's C Rook needed to be on this
Square hence maybe this uh Red Cross
that we see attached to this last move a
Miss from Ala
fua and it's difficult to yeah it's
difficult to move a rook that's already
seemingly developed although a rook on
C1 isn't exactly active uh but it's
because that Rook is loose there in many
of these continuations Bishop C4 Queen
takes B2 now it becomes apparent what I
was trying to indicate earlier that the
C1 Rook is undefended loose pieces drop
off it does not allow The Rook on E1 to
freely take a pawn in its path so aliv
Rizza he is playing this inaccurately
fos of he's up on the clock he's also up
upon Pawn so if things don't clarify
soon I believe that fedos can play for
the upper hand his position it doesn't
look that scary anymore and I love this
move that F just play Queen to B4
defending his loose Pawn attacking
Black's Pawn E7 and threatening to trap
the queen on a
Bishop C4 big big threat now on the
board the black queen is defenseless no
squares to run to so you have to be
really careful now um I guess first
instinct would be to flee lift up your
skirt run back to safety if you're the
black queen but maybe something more
ambitious as well for fed he's a very
ambitious player he didn't grab that
pawn on A2 just to run away with his
Queen uh so big big moments ahead in
this game uh but evaluation Bar says
roughly level and I think for now we
have to trust it uh let's zoom out to
the bird's eye view let's see if the
other games have caught up in terms of
excitement right now and uh okay we see
on the left of your screens Dennis lazic
against Maxim vasra it's a rook end game
level porns level pieces feels like it's
fizzling out towards a draw Martinez
against napesi also level in a rook and
night end
game my favor npom nish's chances but
roughly level for now and uh wle so
against Magnus Carlson um Robert Tanya
what do you think should we stick with
our current game or go to one of those
uh simplified
positions I think we have to head over
to magnus's game he's up a pawn
currently pieces look active but Wesley
trying to get both his Rooks on the
seventh rank so let's get a quick check
in with Wesley under two minutes on the
clock this time on the defense and
that's super scary when you're playing
against Magnus Carlson an end game that
he's pushing it is so hard to keep
things under control but it looks like
like white has compensation here right
you've got this dark Square Bishop that
can line up on the long diagonal The
Rook from B2 is jumping on to B7 to try
to create some threats yes I see black
is upon Pawn up but to me practically it
looks like Wesley's got his chances what
do you think Robert I love magnus's
position and if we do have a couple
seconds I actually want to point out
that Magnus made four great moves in a
row he earned those exclamation points
because Wesley sacrificed the pawn
thinking that he would probably get it
back quickly and the answer is no he's
not and he does have activity but yeah
if you just go back right before Knight
takes B4 Wesley you know he gave up a
pawn there and that four moves in a row
were ex exclamatory from the black side
you stole the pawn The Rook slid to B3
and then Magnus was able to keep his
extra Pawn this looked like the obvious
try from white but look at how Magnus
danced with his Knights first hitting
the Rook on B3 The Rook sles back then
planting a knight on C2 to save the
Knight that's under attack hitting the
rook in the corner the Rooks slides to
hit the Knight that is now hit twice by
two Rooks and he takes a bishop on F3
Returns His Knight to D4 he does steal a
pawn in this position so was great and
knights jump and jump in to steal a
Destiny's Child song and it landed
Magnus an extra pawn and now we have the
game position which does look like it's
fizzling out I think Wesley had just
enough compensation Tanya you seem to be
right yeah I think so because go on
David I was just going to say you take
it away Tanya but when I first saw this
position on the B ey View didn't count
the pawns correctly I thought okay
Wesley's doing really well but that
beautiful uh kind of sequence of nine
jumps giving black the advantage Tanya
how easy uh is it for Wesley to go this
game towards safely do you
feel it's not going to be easy he's
playing against Magnus he's down upon
and that's never going to be easy but
again I'm just going to reiterate the
fact that this bishop on the long
diagonal is not only doing a great job
on this one but is now going to Target
that other Pawn on A5 and to me it looks
like Magnus has to try to get activity
he needs to jump in with that Rook is he
going to try to somehow find any meeting
net ideas against the white king Rook B3
comes to my mind trying to get player on
the king side I don't think you can go
passive trying to defend that A5 Pawn
what would be your approach with black
if you're pushing for a win here it's
difficult to choose sorry David I was
just going to say it feels like you know
as black you want to activate your king
but you don't have anywhere to go so
David you're the endgame Maestro you
have some loose pawns on A5 and maybe G5
how would you actually approach this
position uh normally I love my end games
when you have some level of stability
and uh you can kind of slowly improve
your pieces unfortunately it's one of
those it's pure calculation I just
wanted to point out Tanya's move Rook B3
it's the most tempting and it would be
super strong if it wasn't for the fact
that white could immediately force a
draw with a check another check and
Black's King actually cannot Escape uh
from these barage of checks so really
frustrating for Magnus you can see that
on the camera uh and if we go back to
the game position after Bishop C3 he's
Frozen he hasn't moved uh what can he do
uh I don't see it I've got to admit um
it's really hard to come up with an idea
Knight to H4 instead he tries going
after that pawn on F3 that straggler but
uh okay at least he's trying to initiate
a race from Magnus Carson and he's given
the black king an extra Escape Square I
think this might be really sneaky if the
black king sneaks out via H7 G6 F5 a bit
later on but Wesley Wow exclamation mark
for that move he correctly assesses that
he can just trade everything off and now
after The Rook comes back and takes this
Pawn G5 is loose A5 is loose uh first he
just defends two pawns down worly so but
he got everything under
control G to say it now I think he's
earned the draw he's done it the Hardway
but he's earned his half
point I'm loving the way Wesley is
handling these complicated position and
you could see the frustration on Magnus
right there I think he missed this idea
of Wesley not snapping up that C5 Pawn
immediately allowing Black's Rook to
jump into the attack with with that B3
square and picking up that F3 Pawn but
he just simply sidesteps with the King
it's what we saw in round one as well
Wesley with the black pieces sacrificed
the peace went for the most combative
option uh option and Magnus was on the
back foot and it looks like Magnus did
everything created everything in this
game got the maximum and yet it's not
enough Wesley's defense has been on the
active side today it's more of the
offense kind of a defense I'm loving it
this end game here it's even material at
long last but but I think that white may
have some good chances because the a
pawn Knights are slow moving pieces you
have to watch out for a passer on the
flank but the F3 Pawn a light Square
hard to defend with a dark squore Bishop
so both sides have their pluses here and
Wesley he's taking the safest approach
bringing his Bishop back keeping that
Knight honest to the G5 pawn and we may
see a repetition so I do think this one
is fully equal but if we don't mind if
we can go to the bird's eyee view one of
the other games that is still going that
one looks like it's anyone's r race and
it is a pawn race between Jose Martinez
second from the left here and yand
pomi wow look at that porn race also we
should mention fuja according to the B
at least has a winning Advantage a big
big attack but let's jump into that game
Martinez against the pom Nishi um we're
seeing some checks we're seeing some
moves here it's all about the quality of
porns not about the quantity black being
a porn up in that game and uh okay also
about the clock quality here with Jos
Martinez down to 20 seconds again he's
really living life on the edge on uh
kind of both Bard and clock I wanted to
say Black's got a great Advantage the
pawn running down but white does have
just enough counterplay not just is this
Pawn hanging but the Knight would then
be hanging behind it and uh some
calculation to be done
Nishi help me out uh T do you see any
good way for black to uh defend this
Pawn while keeping his dreams alive of
pushing for Glory you really want to
push that a pawn but the D E5 Pawn was
hanging so he defends it he saves me
from your question David such a
difficult one to answer how do you go
ahead in this position it's all about
the race now the knight from E3 can also
perhaps go back to F5 fighting against
the G Pawn as well black a pawn up but
we just uh with three minutes on the
clock for nepo and just 18 seconds for
uh Jos Pim he has to keep the tension on
the board he has to try to get that gwn
moving I think this is trouble and I see
the eval bar is equal but I think Yan
pesi good score his come back win in
this one Robert I'm totally with you
because look at Jam he's slowing down
trying to figure it out he does put his
King on the last file if you take that
pawn A4 there could be some checkmating
Nets against it and will Rook G4 defends
the A4 Pawn by hitting the Knight and
whoa that's a huge decision what happens
if black takes that pawn I think A4 is
Untouchable if you take this Pawn now
you walk into a pin on the fourth rank
so he wisely throws in a check first
he's asking the black king where it's
going and wow this is incredible play
incredible defense by Jam here because
now if the black king steps forward
where it wants to go the White Knight
drops back with a check this Pawn will
drop then the a pawn will drop and
Black's pawns collapse like dominoes so
he has to go back if he wants to keep
this game alive but suddenly the White
Knight jumps forward and goes to grab
the C Pawn all of the night Forks all of
the KN jumps smile on the face of NPI
frustrated I think by this just Rock
Solid defense from his opponent on the
back foot here again J them how is he
doing this living life on the edge but
always seems to have a trick up his
sleeve and it's on the clock he's got
less than 10 seconds he still manages to
do it but there's so much drama on the
other boards we're going to quickly P up
P pull up our bird's eye view we've got
a result coming in as Dennis lazovic
holds Maxim Vash grab for the second
game in a row meanwhile massive massive
drama on the Wesley board as Wesley gets
flagged Robert what
happened I'm very surprised but it looks
like on that board that magnus's pieces
were infiltrating in the white King was
in some danger we will get more
information if it was a connection issue
or Wesley just wasn't keeping an eye on
the clock but I'm keeping an eye on the
board on the absolute right hand side of
our screen fedos of he was under attack
but as I look at the position as it
currently stands he has two minor pieces
for a rook so fed say have lost game one
he's suddenly willing himself to victory
in game two it would appear as he's got
a runaway passer on the a file and two
minor pieces a knight and Bishop for a
rook that's extra
material oh and FIA made that move with
three of a second left so frustrated
here there's nothing that can be done I
was going to say black porn is just now
going to push and first he defends it
two pieces will beat a rook especially
in conjunction with this black awn white
simply cannot fight here without this
Pawn even then might black might be
better but fua he had a winning attack
he let it slip took his finger off the
button for one second and Strike Back
comeback from F fed in this match
actually the Black Knight now can just
come into C2 in the next few moves and
push this Pawn for Glory there's no way
it's going to be stopped first he
activates his King closing this one out
we're going to see another uh equal
match here another tight match after
this miraculous comeback I've got to say
from fedf proving that greed was good he
played provocative chess But ultimately
should be
rewarded well he didn't just want to
make a draw and have to rely on future
games and I just want to note that fedos
he kind of is a miracle worker how he
beat vid guti in the ultimate round of
the world rapid championship and fedos
of ended up as the silver medalist so he
has had bad positions before and still
won them here in this position it's
hopeless for white that a pawn two minor
pieces for The Rook it's easy for
Vladimir at this point fora looking
frustrated on the camera and Yi has got
to be feeling the frustration as well as
his game ends in a draw just bam holds a
difficult difficult end game with just
seconds on the clock down upon he does
it again which means that Yan is also
still playing catch up meanwhile fedos
can he get the job done can he level it
and he does it as aliad throws in the
dble he resigns FV is back in the
match oh what a boss move there he wins
the match gives up his Knight to promote
his pawn and then just stands up he
knows that he uh survived through a
really difficult game there and gets an
all important win fua again that Trend
continues he seems to win lose win lose
same from his tataa steel tournament so
a bit of frustration but still in a good
spot in the match uh I think we will
recap that Magnus Carlson game as well
in a moment but uh these are the results
so far in the quarterfinals of division
one we're two games it's halfway through
the winnner quarterfinals and Dennis
laic Maxim VRA remains a level match
meanwhile Ali Resa fuja Vladimir fedos
have also leveled but a completely
different storyline with two decisive
games FY of striking back levels the
match Jose Martinez he continues his
birthday week f as he's still in the
lead against Yan pomi Magnus Carlson
does a surprising turnaround we thought
that everything was under control for
Wesley so he managed to survive the
worst but then Magnus suddenly taking
the win Robert how much of a surprise is
that for you cuz I'm shocked right now
it was shocking indeed because Wesley so
he is great at all time shows including
bullet but sometimes when pressure keeps
mounting it's hard to show resistance
forever so I want to give credit to
Magnus Carlson for finding his chances I
also want to give another shout out to
Vladimir fedos winning on demand against
ala fuja sure fuja doesn't always show
stability but beating that guy oh that's
difficult so congrats to fosa but the
job is not done we still have two games
to go in these
matches yes and it is the action the
drama continu news in the chessable
Masters and of course we will be back
with more as there are two more rapid
games remaining but just to get a Breo
we're going to take a quick stroll
through Paris with the French defense
Maestro Anish Kiri take a
[Music]
look
sh
welcome to a world where each game
writes a new story with endless
possibilities and surprising twists we
present the next big new tournament the
freestyle chess goat challenge at the
Forefront of this epic chess spectacle
is none other than Magnus Carlson the
former world champion facing his first
duel with the reigning world champion
ding Len since his title victory in
addition to this top duel Carlson has
selected six other top Challengers to
make the tournament especially
exciting be sure to watch all the games
on the live stream at chess.com and on
our
at the luxurious weisson House Resort
experience the thrill and fascination of
Chess in a completely new
[Music]
light when I saw her for the first time
it was love at first
sight I love how rich and complex she is
how sharp and principle her first
steps how graceful her
movement Paris is a city of
[Music]
love
I've come to find my
love for the French
[Music]
defense
oh
[Music]
welcome back to chable Masters everyone
we still got two big rapid games coming
up and talking about games Robert if you
were just about to play against David
Howell what would be the one spell that
you would cast on him right before the
game you know it's a good question cuz
to steal a line from Nina Simone I'll
put a spell on you and I think unlike
the natural disasters in the world it's
natural disaster on my chest board so
I'm going to use tornado against you
David I hope that messes you up ah
Robert I'm going to throw back a freeze
spell on you and hope that that
gives me a bit of luck in the
game well Robert's Frozen I'm sure some
of the players in the Chesser bable
Masters would also like to cast UNF
phrase Rober would also like to cast a
spell on their opponents as they're
playing catchup as we go into round
three but you can play some spell chess
on Annie chess use the command aness in
chat or go to annie.com for all the
spell chess action and a spell fun on
your opponents we're about to have some
F in the chessel Masters as we enter
round three let's take a look at our
score lines just before the action
starts and there we are Wesley so needs
to win a game to level the match Ali Roa
fuja Vladimir FV two decisive games it's
level in their matchup meanwhile Yan
neishi is struggling against Jose
Martinez and I know Robert you're a jpam
fan you've spoken so much about his
style his speed in online chess what is
it that makes him so strong
he he plays practically he is able to be
a bullet Beast he plays in all the
bullet braws in chess.com he's been in
the bullet Chess Championship so is his
Play Perfect absolutely not does he
sometimes struggle in the openings yes
but he knows when to make these quick
decisions and how to use his clock
wisely and you can't punish him when he
is down under 20 seconds like you can
other players so Jose he's very solid he
is hard to you know take down in a
tactical Skirmish he's just a very
allaround player and one that uses his
time when he's down to his final seconds
quite
wisely and jpam has played over 100,000
games on chess.com David and I know
you're someone who's always playing
bullet Blitz right before commentary
starts I've got to ask you before we get
into the chess action how many games
have you played on chess.com well I
don't think I can match this man's uh
efforts on chess.com uh I know I'm in
the tens of thousands but 100,000 games
I mean it's no coincidence that the top
players become good at chess it's uh
like any sport it's like playing an
instrument you have to practice practice
practice and Jos Bam's taken that to the
extreme but it's paying off now and uh
as Robert said a practical player he
never seems to get flustered no matter
how badly the opening goes even a middle
game slip up he always comes back strong
and now it's up to NPI to come back
strong a point down still with only two
games to go he'll have to start taking
risks and that's where J B becomes even
more dangerous um this is not going the
way of the favorite on P
and uh yeah I can't wait to see what he
tries next y pishi I also can't wait to
see how Wesley so reacts recovers from
that heartbreaking defeat on the brink
of a draw against Magnus in that
previous game we kind of wrote it off
but nope uh something went a bit wrong
on the board on the clock and Wesley he
needs to strike back needs to come back
stronger yeah and Wesley so losing with
the white pieces in game two that got to
hurt he starts with black he needs to
make sure to keep things under control
if Magnus wins with white in this one
that would be match over for Wesley so
Wesley has to keep things on the check
Magnus starts with the Kings Pawn
opening are we expecting a sicilian
Robert well when Wesley's in must-win
territory he often chooses the Sicilian
but why does he have to win this game if
he draws with black he does get a final
game with the white pieces and let's not
forget it's not like he was lost on the
board in that second game he lost on the
clock so for Wesley I think this is the
smart thing to do if Magnus wants the
force the draw in some Berlin let him do
that and use the white pieces in game
four big indicator Wesley so's opening
Choice the Berlin defense that he would
have been happy with solidity and uh
just a draw with black straight off the
bat Magnus with his opening Choice
playing Pawn to D3 just slow pawn moves
here defending the center not allowing
any uh quick transitions here not
allowing pieces to fly off the board
Magnus hinting that he wants a
full-blooded fight as well so uh great
to see from both sides I'm loving the
fact that Magnus has kept the tension
and Wesley's last move just shuffling
his Rook towards the center not the main
move but uh yeah just keeping the
tension alive Magnus is probably the
world's leading expert in these slower
types of Spanish opening this is one of
those branches uh so I'm just uh Curious
now to see how he approaches this next
phase of the game all pieces on the
board and likely to stay that way for a
long long time now and uh you guys uh
I'm going to ask you first t are you as
optimistic after seeing this opening
Choice as I am of a real battle in this
clash in this third game you know when
Wesley wants a draw it's hard to imagine
us getting a game but that said Magnus
goes for a line that does keep the
tension on the board keeps the pieces on
the board I think it's going to be a
slow one but Magnus will play this out I
don't believe we're going to see too
many trades early on it's still a closed
position it's going to be a slow
strategic fight I'm going to go one step
ahead and predict the result result in
this I think we're going to get a game
four in this match David I think
regardless of how Magnus chooses to go
on in the middle game it will end in a
draw but Robert you seem to not agree
with me in this one no I just like your
prediction I think that you Wesley he is
showing that he's willing to fight for
the center by striking with D5 we are
just going to see him recapture but the
fact that he hasn't automatically played
yet it indicates to me that he's not so
certain about what to do here and that
should favor Magnus so this isn't some
deep theoretical position at least not
from the black side you could tell by
Wesley he has yet to move but unlike
some of the other games that we're
seeing it feels like they're just
playing a neutral position to see who
plays the better
chess and I was about to say Wesley he
paused for a reason and uh Robert uh you
were talking about maybe capturing it
back in the center there were a bunch of
choices you could take with the Knight
with the queen he actually
counterattacks against the white bishop
and this is a rare move but it's a known
move Lebon aronian one of the leading
experts again in the Spanish opening
uh he has employed it on occasion
hitting this bishop and it's actually a
pawn sacrifice Magnus takes the Knight
and he could even have taken this Pawn
on C6 but then his Pawn would have
dropped in the center so now allowing
Wesley to regain the material expecting
the move takes D5 here and yes black has
shattered pawns a shattered structure
but black is supremely active and for
example after a trade of pieces on the C
Square opposite color Bishops into the
mix as well so maybe at least
symbolically white has a small Edge
Magnus removing as as much risk as
possible but Wesley playing ambitious
chess uh nice to see and uh clearly both
players they might spent a bit of time
but still uh in their opening
preparation I
feel yeah and if Magnus doesn't capture
that Bishop on C5 it would give Wesley
the option to actually fall back with
the bishop to B6 on the next move and
keep the bishop at Advantage with the
dile open the D3 Pawn week I think that
would give Wesley something to play on
for I'm expecting Magnus to snap up the
bishop and go for the opposite color
Bishop position that you're talking
about but with the asymmetrical Pawn
structure I think we've got a game in
our hands this is a very non-standard
Berlin no this is not standard at all
yeah sorry David I was just going to say
that those bad pawns for black those
could be long-term weaknesses but the
opposite color Bishops that we're likely
to see that should compensate but not
fully equalized Magnus has been known to
win positions with even less of an
advantage than this he's been known to
win all sorts of positions actually both
of these two have and uh yeah I I was
just going to say I like it tan I love
your predictions just that enthusiasm
about seeing a real fight in this one
and Magnus going for it big move on the
board D4 he drops it in and uh now
there's a big dilemma ahead for Wesley
if you take this Pawn you might be hit
in the center I'm not sure which way
Magnus intends to recapture either he'll
take on E5 with his own Pawn maybe
potentially with a knight uh but if you
take on D4 you're in for a bit of
suffering I was going to say oh this one
I'm reluctant to suggest because
suddenly if the Queens come off then
Black's Pawn structure the weaknesses
become more pronounced so Wesley I feel
has to keep the Queens on the board do
not trade you're facing the best end
game player of all time I've even got
magnus's book behind me don't go into
the end game he'll grind you down so
keep the Queens on Queen H5 yeah this
one is still roughly in the balance but
I don't like this little uh this last
couple of moves from Wesley so I think
now it is getting critical already keep
the Queens on best way to keep your
chances alive in this m and so the
T-shirt saying that Robert that don't go
into end games with Magnus Carlson but I
think in this particular position Wesley
will definitely not do that expecting
him to try to slide over to the king
side Queen H5 get a knight on G4 get a
bishop on G4 try to play for more Robert
I'm keeping my optimism that we're gonna
still have a long game in this one well
I was first gonna say David is very
humble because he co-wrote that book he
know had to grind like a grandm himself
and then I'm thinking this is the type
of position where evaluation bar to deci
side of our board here says white maybe
ever so slightly better or it's equal
but if Wesley had traded the Queens I
think Magnus wins that position the
majority of the time double pawns are
terrible to defend when you don't have
much time on the clock especially double
isolated pawns because a Pawn's best
friend is another Pawn David if you
could just pick up the pawn on C6 for a
second just like hover with it and put
it on B6 if that pawn were on B6 then
I'm like all right this is just even not
a big deal because the pawns can defend
one another but with the Pawns stacked
the way they are it means that this is a
long-term weakness that isn't going
anywhere and in particular the C7 Pawn
if a bishop safely goes out to F4 that
C7 Pawn you have to tie a rook down to
it you don't want to use a piece that is
worth five points in value to protect
the piece that's worth just one so I do
think the long-term chances are in
White's favor and that's why Wes is
operating the short term Queen H5 and a
you said a bishop to G4 a knight to G4
use the open E file you need to play
dynamically to compensate for your
ruined queenside Pawn
structure yeah super instructive there
and getting to the essence of the
position this is going through the
players Minds as well that's pretty much
what Wesley was uh telling himself as he
made that decision he likes his end
games as well so the Temptation would
have been there trade Queens but then
you break it down then you think okay
it's all about the weaknesses you're
playing a great endgame expert you don't
want to suffer now at least it's not
oneway traffic and uh okay Bishop to G5
very testing move aiming to shatter not
just the queenside pawns which have
already been broken but also Black's
King side Bishop takes Knight a huge
strategic positional threat now needs to
be guarded against somehow but moving
the Knight there's not that many safe
squares for it do you Counterattack with
your black Bishop bring it out to G4
play a bit of mirroring copycat games
there you could aim to shatow White's
kingside structure feels like this game
is really livened up just in the last
couple of moves um what comes to your
mind big threat on the board yeah after
this last move by Magnus my optimism
seems to be fading a little bit because
Bishop takes Knight and Wesley's got to
try to go on the defense with this I
really like the idea of jumping in with
the with his own Bishop to G4 but those
trades and he does it Bishop G4 has been
played but it looks like it might just
fizzle out with all the upcoming trades
white could just capture on F6 white
would be take back on F3 and I think at
the end of all this sequence you either
take back on F3 U maybe we can have the
moves David and you can help me out with
it but even if you were just to fall
back with your Bishop to e Bishop E5 is
not possible because the Rook takes on
E5 and that would just lose the game on
the spot you think I think you have to
take on F3
here Bishop H4 or does that run into
Rook E4 there is no way to hide with the
bishop no way suddenly things would turn
around as you say Tanya otherwise white
would be loving life but unfortunately
this double attack just in time uh to
kick white off balance and uh just to
mention the other point you were
highlighting in this position black has
at very minimum a check
hitting the white king and now you can
uh just take these off and yes shattered
pawns but without Bishops without
Knights far harder to attack these Pawn
islands and white not enjo exactly
enjoying life either with his structure
so everything's balanced here this is
likely draw this would actually be a
logical conclusion to the game Robert
this is exactly what seems to be
happening and if that's the case then a
draw will keep Magnus with a one-point
lead so I do trust Wesley at this stage
with the Queens coming off the board
maybe Magnus can work endgame magic but
it does seem very likely a draw will be
the result so why don't we zoom out of
this game look at our other three
contests because with eight players in
this double elimination bracket I think
that there is a lot up for grabs as
Magnus he's in charge but some of the
other matches the favorites namely Yan
naami and aliv fuja they have not had a
steady first couple games and I look
second from the left right now yand pomi
with white playing a close structure and
then I look all the way to the right fos
sa against fuia it seems like every time
we look at their games they are just
like throwing axes at one another they
are not dodging a fight yeah I think we
should jump over there fed against fua
um because remember it is 1-1 it's only
been decisive games so far and there's a
big double attack on the board black is
actually a whole piece up but this was
intentional from FV we see a double
attack we see a fork which piece has to
move it's obviously the queen here but
where do you move her how do you get
into White's camp White's King a bit
Airy here and having pushed the pawn to
G4 I think fed will be feeling a bit
nervous uh very logical move forcing
white to regain the material and white
will temporarily be a pawn up but it
looks like Black's ready to chip away at
the white Kings side structure um
evaluation Bar says 0.0 Tanya what's
your vote whose position would you
choose I would pick black all day every
day here I'm loving the activity The
Rook can slide into d8 your idea of H5
opening up the H file looks extremely
scary I could win a Tempo inserting Rook
to d8 if you go Queen E2 The Rook will
come to the second rank as well with a
Tempo meanwhile if the queen leaves the
connection with the F3 Square I'm mind
to move Queen F3 I want to pick up your
H3 Pawn so some really tempting options
for black in this position and he goes
for H5 really like this David you
pointed it out I think the things are
getting very tricky for fedf he's the
one who's up a PA but he could be down a
king if he's not careful there's one
problem for black otherwise he might
already be winning if he could Castle
queenside then the game is pretty much
over it's uses your plan of Rook to d8
but it also gets your king to safety
while connecting your Rooks maybe you
double in the H file later but because
you cannot legally Castle through check
that does not allow fuja to get his King
fully away from the center of the board
and if you play Rook d8 well your king
doesn't want to go to the short side
because you're trying to attack on that
flank so King G2 what a response from
feros he's allowing the H file to open
Rook d8 still available and Bishop takes
E4 check becomes another option that
wasn't available a turn ago now you can
play it because the check against the
white king but you may see your own King
Be In Harm's Way after a series of
Trades so this is a critical moment for
fuja if you don't take this Pawn on e4
now maybe white will soon play Pawn to
F3 and try to keep the extra Pawn so you
need to play precise chest from both
sides here it's a messy position but I
would say that I think black has a
little bit more to prove right now
I actually want to go back and just
mentioned Tanya's move Rook to d8 maybe
it was slightly more accurate to play on
the previous move because now this looks
so natural but white has the move Queen
to F3 if the Queens come off we talked
about it in the other game suddenly it
would clearly favor white not just upper
Pawn but this bishop will be locked out
the game and uh due to the slightly odd
Pawn structure especially on the queen
side white would have a long-term
Advantage so uh if black flict in this
move earlier this queen F3 idea was not
available he could pretty much have that
move for free white would have been for
to choose a worst Square for example one
like this with the queen but this would
have allowed the black rook in so
sometimes move order is uh really
important here suddenly black would have
a big big Advantage big attack on the
white king and uh Instead This simply
isn't possible just to mention the other
moves after King to G2 Bishop takes E4
as Robert pointed out this is committal
you win your Pawn back but at the cost
of giving up castling rights for good
this check and the black king sitting on
f8 this is a lottery to me I don't know
whose King is weaker but the players
have to work that out as well so right
now big decision ahead for fua feels
like fed have maybe mixed up his opening
slightly but fua failing to punish him
so far still fine for black Robert
thinking more to prove for fua I'm
inclined to agree um also Pon PA white
would take back with the queen if the
Queens disappear clearly white is the
one in charge um I'm loving the games
between these two I've got to say today
just really entertaining
chess we've had two decisive games
between these two players Ali R are the
first win fedos here with black pieces
striking in the second one and both
complete roller coasters and this one
looks like it's going that way even the
position that you had on the analysis
board David with Black's King on f8
White's King in the open as well with
the FG and H Pawn advanced in front of
him it's anyone's game and I think a
decisive result in this one is very
likely as well Robert what would be your
prediction do you think the players are
going to try and trade off the pieces
along the eile or we're going to get a
bit of a blood bath against each other's
King I I think that we are going to get
that blood bath I mean there is no
hiding at this point and for fuja who is
well down on the clock the last thing he
wants to see is a queen trade so he
wants to play Pawn takes G4 but he sees
that the White Queen will just snack on
that pawn right back and white is upon a
head everything does look relatively
solid for him so fuja you could see that
he is not happy to be in this position
he thought that he would have easier
forms of compensation that there'd be a
direct path to regaining his Pawn
deficit but no it's not that clear
taking on e4 it does restore material
equality but the white king will be no
safer uh EXC the black king will be no
safer than the white king with a check
along the E file I don't think that fuer
wants to be in this position and
Vladimir FV he can make him pay with
this lead on the
clock oh he spent so much time pretty
much half of his remaining time or more
on that one move eventually does regain
the pawn and uh we'll see Fed have
surely just get rid of that Bishop one
of the potential attackers of the white
king and that whole variation we showed
uh with the two kind of Airy Kings it's
just Mutual attacking chances despite
the fact that there are all these trades
um in the meantime um key position here
but let's briefly zoom out I just wanted
to do a quick Roundup the other games
still in a quieter uh kind of mood the
other players uh a draw between Vash lra
and lazovic they really are racing
towards the Armageddon now I think
that's the most balanced match of the
day um nothing to choose between the two
of them so far the second game from your
left yanomi against Martinez very very
symmetrical I will say that NPI maybe
the slightly happier of the two uh he
has a better Bishop Carlson against
wesle so also racing towards a draw so
this is where the action's happening
Nomi against Martinez and fev against
fuja um I'm going to vote that we
quickly jump into npom Martinez before
coming back to see how fev and F deal
with the weaknesses of their kings
um so let's jump over there and see
whether yand pomi can mount a
comeback my first instinct is correct so
what do we think uh Robert is white
slightly better I say slightly because
it's tension packed uh NPI as he aims to
launch the comeback let's look at that
game because uh we saw another draw
between Maxim vasher lra and Dennis
Lazar we apologize that we haven't
looked at those games but because
there's been no separation but between
those two players very little room for
excitement when your players are playing
nearly perfect chess uh there it's not
like you are going to be able to have a
tactical finish to the game so we look
at this game on the other hand well if a
white knight could get to D5 white is
definitely in charge if a black knight
could get to D4 white can actually snap
a knight off there so that knight from
C7 is looking to reroute and white
doesn't have easy access to D5 I look at
the clock huge lead for yand pomi in
this position I do feel like he should
be slightly preferred because his Bishop
on E3 attacks pawns C5 and H6 the bishop
on f8 it's a very defensive piece with
no open diagonals to work with so I
would take the open B file the dark
Square Bishops but I do like that
rerouting of the Knight for black so
small pluses for each side leads to a
relatively equal
position the speed t with which Jose's
playing he's always down on the clock
really early in these games but somehow
at the critical moments he changes the
tempo and suddenly an immediate reaction
hitting this loose White Knight which
was defended how impressed are you just
he seems to always have a reply up his
sleeve something in store super
impressive right and especially the
speed with which he plays when he's down
on seconds and it's not just about the
speed because more important is the
Precision which he brings on with the
speed he goes for the most direct most
challenging options it's never about
neutralizing the position trying to
simplify it because this position itself
we see is really complicated it's going
to become more of a mess as the game
progresses the Black Knight eying the D4
Square now but I do agree with your
initial feeling there David that white
with this bishop the black pawn stuck on
C5 on the color of White's Bishop long
term it just feels that white will have
that slight Edge now White's Knight
going towards D5 I do like Yan neomi's
position here I think jpim has a big
defensive task ahead of him yeah because
if you ever capture a knight on D5 that
really helps out White's Pawn structure
I think strategically that would be lost
if you can imagine a black knight going
to f just to stop a knight from getting
to D5 so you see here comes the White
Knight Black's Knight can jump in first
a knight on D4 and a knight on D5 they
don't actually threaten anything that's
the good news uh so for both of these
players they're jockeying for important
squares but I I just don't see where the
knockout blow is and that's why I'm
looking at the clock I do like y pal
she's lead on time I think that for
josam there aren't and that's Jose for
everyone who doesn't know his online
username that for Jose Martinez it's not
like he has a four series of Trades that
liquidates board allows an inch closer
to the draw there's a lot of life left
in this position because you could see
the makings of an attack and wow what a
move that was Knight instead going to D4
goes F4 do not fall for it don't take
this Knight on F4 because after e takes
F4 David the queen on C3 is under attack
as is the Knight on
E3 tactics Galore suddenly out of the
blue we're talking about a slow
maneuvering game not many variations to
show but this would be disastrous for
white immediately so do not touch this
Knight if we go back to the game Knight
to F4 this was reacted to with a retreat
a really sad move from npom nesi but an
important necessary evil to block out
this black queen The Black Queen if she
could have done would have slid nearer
the white king and look how both players
such practical players you can tell how
experienced they are in Blitz chest
tucking their kings away safely to bed
just saying okay these kings are safe
they feel safer than wle so with his
blanket right now and uh now it becomes
a bit more of a maneuvering game yet
again npon
begging for the Queens to disappear
because then the white king will
eternally be safe I wouldn't be avoid
kind of avoiding that Queen trade
actually if I were J I think taking that
Queen off would have guided him closer
towards safety but keeping the queen on
may be more ambitious this is the only
thing you've got to make sure her
majesty here doesn't get trapped she's
hit but she had a safe square and uh
yeah this one's anyone's game so many
tactics suddenly popping out of the
woodwork uh this is a
pin don't know in terms of the momentum
of the game it feels like it's up and
down and both sides testing each other
Knight back to D5 and just he's holding
his own with just 40 seconds left on the
clock he's aiming to jump in really
symmetrical really balanced chances but
it feels like at some point someone is
going to kind of press that chaos button
and I'm not sure whether this symmetry
is going to last for too much
longer I think Jose pressed that chaos
button when he made that move Knight to
F4 we've seen these last couple of moves
coming in with Tempo White's Knight has
landed on D5 now the bishop going back
to E1 has only retreated to go further
to C3 trying to line up on this diagonal
once the bishop lands on C3 you're also
eyeing the E5 Pawn uh meanwhile Jose's
Queen drops back he's touching the 30
second Mark eventually white Black's
Knight has to land on D4 Robert are we
expecting Knight D4 he goes H5 instead
he's trying to fix the problem piece
that dark Square Bishop it's staring
into its own pawns bad Bishops defend
good pawns but you to create a good
Bishop so H6 to the C1 diagonal that's
some open lines but I do like how this
game has been going for Yan nepi he's
been kicking Black's forces back now
that the Queens are off there's no
active play and Jose he is a fantastic
resourceful Defender but he likes
activity now he is saddled with defense
the C5 Pawn the E5 pawn and the knight
from E6 ever moves watch out for Knight
C7 to hit your lonely A6 pawn it is
slightly better for white but for now
Jose has everything under
control routing his Bishop there 16
seconds on the clock the big question is
whether he kind of uh can hold his Nerf
history says that yes he can J spem here
but the black Bishop I think he's just
going to do what you said Robert he's
just going to sit on a defensive square
and he's going to hope that he can build
what we call a fortress just no entry
points for white sooner or later white
will need to open up a second front he's
trying to get in with his Bishop now
that is quickly swiftly shut down white
will need to open the king side whether
that's with a move like Pawn to H4 maybe
Pawn to G3 now that jpam has uh kind of
block the dart squares he'll need to
open a second front of attack it's like
an army H you're not getting anywhere on
one side your opponent's blocking you
fighting you off you have to open uh
switch their attentions to the other
flank of the board there's going to be a
lot of grinding in this end game as the
knights are jumping around but the
pieces are also jumping around on our
other board we're going to pull up our
bird's eye view of the remaining two
games meanwhile an update that Magnus
Wesley ended in a draw Maxim Dennis
lazic ended in a draw as well but look
at that on the right Ali RZA versus
fedos the Queens are on the board the
Rooks are on the board a queen trade
offered and we go into a rook Pawn end
game is this going to fizzle out into a
draw it looks like it I mean look at the
pieces that remain black is two pawns
ahead on the right hand side of her
screen now make it one but look at the
B7 Pawn in The Rook site the second Rook
on E2 will jump forward and well foru is
giving up his Queen side to go for the
king side I think this was a sensible
decision and fedos he likely just defend
his Pawn so I'm looking from left to
right the evaluation bar is more or less
in the center in both these games but
they couldn't be more different we have
a minor piece end game on the left and
Rook end game on the right David you're
like to grind like a grandm which end
game do you
prefer I think uh the one on the right
I've got to say I love this camera angle
we see all the action all the moves um I
think fed against fuja is going to
fizzle out Rook end games do have this
drawish tendency White's Rooks are
active enough and um fuja even if he
wins the pawn in front of the white king
I don't think that's going to get him
anywhere that one destined for a draw
the other one blocked maneuvering slow
still we call it an end game but uh it's
going to go on for a lot lot longer um I
still like npom nish's chances I've got
to say I think he's the one trying to
make the magic happen ultimately it's
all about the clock as well five seconds
for Jose
Martinez he hold his nerve I think both
should be draws with best play but
commentator curse I don't want to
predict too early still a lot of life
left been amazing to see josim and his
control on his nerves as you say David
he's got nerves of Steel we see the C5
Pawn under attack which is 4 seconds the
Knight has to jump to defend it but the
kind of positions he saved and turned
around with just seconds on the clock
has been so impressive impressive in
this uh event so far my question to you
right now is can white actually double
down on that C5 Pawn he does it because
the Black Knight on C6 is tied down to
defend the E5 pawn and now we are seeing
the pawn structure
change the structure change uh this game
has just ended in a draw between fed and
fuja just showing you the final stages
there so let's jump back to that game it
was blocked but no longer the whole
Queens side disappeared Tanya the black
pawns dropped for the white porns and
suddenly the black king active I see no
reason at all barrowing a miracle here
from Nomi for JM to sweat unless there's
a miracle Checkmate in the middle of the
board which it doesn't look like there
is he's walking living life on the edge
here that's what I was looking at David
though like the black king only has F6
right now is that the only Square
available to it so if you could give one
check in a funny way that black king
could have been made it in the center
but of course you don't have enough
pieces remaining for
white is such a yo-yo position with the
checks because black king needs to stay
connected to the E4 Pawn white needs an
extra piece to deliver checkm doesn't
have it I think we're going to see a
repetition
here you see the draw both players lean
back back npom she smiling despite his
deficit Jose Martinez shaking his head
he knows that he lived life on the edge
yet again three games in a row he's been
living on the increment on the added
time I don't know how much longer that
can go on uh he does have white however
in the fourth and final game of uh kind
of the regular time here and uh I don't
know who looks the happier uh yand pishi
just always with his eyebrows ra raised
these
days F she cannot be a happy man right
now he is trailing Jose Martinez who has
a one-point lead Yan pishi has to win on
demand a must win game four coming up in
that matchup as we see the score line 2
to one Chim needs only a draw to advance
in the winners bracket meanwhile Ali Rea
fuja Vladimir fosier with their first
draw of the day in game three but it was
a wild ride Wesley so Magnus Carlson
Wesley has to strike back in the final
rapid game meanwhile d lawick he is
unbreakable with three draws against
Maxim Vash lra what was the stand out
moment for you in this one
David in this round I've got to say it
was probably those end games uh
especially that game between fuja and FV
um there were fireworks at the beginning
but ultimately both players just upping
their game just kind of pulling the
breaks and uh going into solid mode
towards the end um it was tough to call
though it felt like this was just the
players finding their balance kind of
saving energy for the fourth and final
game where some players now in must-win
situations and uh really needing to just
go all in throw everything at the
opponent Robert what are the chances of
us getting an
Armageddon extremely high have you seen
the match between Dennis lavic and Maxim
V God the answer is no because they keep
drawing and Dennis lavic has shown that
his rating may be 2550 2560 but the way
he's performed on the biggest stages the
world rapid the world Blitz the CCT
finals he is well above 2650 level in
the quicker time controls so we see
Magnus on camera we don't see Wesley so
for a second game in a row Wesley is
nowhere to be found when the games are
beginning back in just a few seconds
this is the final game for Wesley has to
win the good news for Wesley and Wesley
fans is that he starts with the white
pieces and I want opening predictions
David what's Wesley going to start with
in this must-win game I don't know what
he's going to start with but I'll say he
will not start with W B3 we saw that too
much in Toronto in the tour finals uh
last year back in December um I think
he's going to start with D4 again he
faced the Kings Indian last time the
Kings Indian allows the opponent
chances but I'm wrong to E4 instead and
what will Wesley do next okay what do
you think we'll see from here could
still be Italian Spanish you still got
options if he goes Bishop to B5 we're
seeing a Berlin is my prediction and
we've got an Italian we've got a game on
our hands Robert we do and often times
in these Italian quiet openings you can
just maneuver for a while but Magnus
Carlson he's really good at maneuvering
he doesn't mind exiting theoretical
Waters as quickly as possible but I do
like this choice right here Bishop to G5
because black often is encouraged to
push the G Pawn up two squares and we
saw in some very important games in the
tatas classical tournament it can get
scary for black if you have to extend
your kingside pawns too far castling
becomes more
Magnus instead drops his Bishop back
black has actually lost a move this
black Bishop came out to C5 and then
dropped back just a couple of moves
later to E7 so that's the justification
as Robert says it's always scary you
never want to touch a pawn especially if
you plan to Castle King side especially
if you only need a draw uh so Magnus now
I've got to say as well his trademark
move he never allows his opponent to
gain space on the flanks A4 he meets
just every single time with A5 uh no
matter uh kind of for better or worse he
will always block on the flanks and
Magnus as if he's hearing me Smiles
there sorry Magnus giving away your
secrets but uh yeah this one I'm
expecting actually Wesley to do a few
funky things maybe he'll drop his Bishop
back in the near future often white
actually delays uh castling delays what
we would normally associate with the
slower Italian games he's there we go he
attacks the pawn and uh yeah it's just
about whether he comes forward with his
Knight now he comes to D2 instead maybe
we'll see a bit of dancing by both
players a bit of maneuvering but uh
shaping up nicely again cal before
what's guaranteed to be a
storm got to be a storm because Wesley
so has got no option but to throw
everything that he's got at Magnus
Carlson in this one it starts slow uh
right now Wesley made the moves Pawn to
C3 always eyeing the D4 Central break to
open things up at the right moment very
often Robert in these position black
wants to try to trade off the light squ
Bishop is Bishop B6 a move on magnus's
radar here it's it's on my radar it's
definitely on his radar and then the
question for Wesley is do I trade right
away do I allow black to take me on C4
because I have a knight that can capture
back and the white Bishop can also slide
up the board to B5 just to put a little
pressure on the pony on C6 so there are
options available to White the D3 to D4
push is clearly what the players will be
looking for but for what you don't want
to rush that decision because as soon as
you push your D- Pawn your E4 Pawn feels
a little bit looser so I would say the
slight Advantage for white is because of
the quality of the minor pieces in
particular the bishop on E7 it's a
passive piece and the uh Bishop on C4
for white already developed the Black
Knights completely restricted especially
the Knight on C6 so I would say those
are the small little pluses here but
it's not much and Magnus he's very solid
and he has a lot of experience from the
black side of these
setups and I want to mention we saw a
feature chat up briefly saying only
Wesley would play the Italian in a
must-win uh must-win situation must-win
game and that might have been true five
years ago 10 years ago but nowadays all
the top ground Masters play the Italian
if they want to win because this is one
of the only openings you guarantee
pretty much all the pieces on the board
past move 15 past move 20 um so it's
just about building that tension it's
psychological you have so many options
at your disposal Magnus chooses to drop
his Knight back watch out for Magnus
shuffling his King out the way and then
unleashing the F Pawn potentially a bit
later since this bishop is a bit of a
Target but uh yeah the players they're
allowed to St their creativity I used to
play the Italian when I was a child used
to get criticized for it by everyone my
coaches fellow players they were like do
you not understand chess it's so boring
but uh little did they know it would
become the most trendy opening uh pretty
much worldwide at all levels and I like
to see Wesley kind of play in this mood
delay castling as we predicted just uh
bringing his Knight to the center and uh
yeah what do you make are you as excited
as I am
Robert no the answer is a definitive
resounding absolutely not and I think
because Wesley's in a must-win position
he is going to try to maneuver before
castling just create a little bit of
confusion but if we talk about stylistic
play I mean if we can zoom out to our
bird's eye view because Wesley is not
the only person who needs to win this
game yand pomi needs to win and we see
second from the left he is the black
pieces the engine it will favor white in
a position like that again the second
board from the left hand side but it's
because yand the pal she can't have a
dry position where we just trade pieces
he needs to keep things a bit ambiguous
not allow clear tension so you see the
difference uh of play When people's
backs are against the wall and they have
to
win and uh judging from this bird eye
view what catches your eye first I mean
uh we've talked about this game Magnus
Carson against Wesley we'll check back
in a bit later npom Nishi wow maybe we
do have to jump there because uh he's
really being provocative he's really
foregoing everything we're taught as
youngsters um Robert I think you called
it that might be the game of this at
least early stages and uh let's go over
to it question mark attached to this
last move by npom but how does josen
punish it he's actually up on the clock
for once this is a first today game
review is too objective he needs to win
with the black pieces that is his
objective so it's a question mark move
when you look at the evaluation bar but
it's the way to play for a win in order
to create chaos you have to take huge
risks so yanomi he's doing that and for
a change he's the one who's down on the
clock because he is spending time to
make sure that his decisions are
Justified and for Jose he's playing s so
Tanya I I know as soon as I asked the
question you're going to say no way but
would you ever play this way from the
black side when you need to win and a
draw is the equivalent to a loss no way
Jose is what I'm thinking right now
because G5 for me it's really exciting
to see you on the board as a commentator
but wait a second the black king is not
castled have haven't completed the
development yet and the gepon moving
twice up the board uh it's something
that's really fun to watch very brave
and I think you're absolutely on point
that for Yan neomi it's a move made out
of the matth situation more than a move
that he wants to make but to me it just
looks like White's the one who's going
to create the initiative and Jose goes
for it with blackking in the center he's
eyeing up opening up off the E Line e
Tak D6 was a big threat Yan pami
immediately captures it what are you
going to recapture with because to me
David all options are equally tempting
but I would say I want to pick it up
with a d Pawn right now or is G4
something that I need to be careful
about certainly as you indicate there
Tanya you need to hesitate you need to
calculate a little bit but ultimately I
think the most ambitious move is the
best one taking with the pawn let's show
some moves it does look like it walks
into G4 and if you were had to move this
Knight suddenly your Pawn in the center
would drop uh evaluation Bar says still
pretty good for white still good
compensation but at least your path to
Victory is far less clear luckily you
don't have to move pieces that are
attacked you can Counterattack and pawn
to E6 would simply be uh devastating for
black it's a battering ram this Pawn
hitting the Knight hitting this pawn and
if black has the tarity to take on F3
then uh I'm not even sure what you do
next but for uh example just to
highlight one checkmating pattern now
you give a check kick the meing back and
Bishop to G6 you're going to make the
kiss of death on F7 in the near future
um this would be disastrous but also the
logical conclusion of this variation
we're showing uh if we go back to the
game position he's still hesitating no
he has just taken this pawn and pawn to
E6 is a killer threat a winning threat
if black tries to block one final
comment here suddenly you open up a new
hole for the White Knight to jump into
this would be a check a double attack a
fork pretty much game over at least at
this level so npom she living life on
the edge he needs to and uh he's tried
something a bit special here he actually
took on F3 three wow giving up the
bishop pair counterintuitive but he's
hoping that once the White Knight takes
now he'll play E6 and there's nothing no
Knight no horsey Pony that can jump into
D6 yet at least so still I'm goingon to
say ugly for black but he's alive and
that's all Nish needs to do for now to
keep his chances alive in this
match me Robert it looks like he's
barely alive he's given up such a strong
Bishop on B7 the light Squad Bishop
White's got the bishop there White's
fully developed that Bishop from D3 can
actually land on B5 I'm pinning a knight
on D7 I want to go Rook D1 next and win
the game on the spot G6 G5 was you know
they say Brave and well super risky is
two sides of the same coin for me G5
just turned out to be just a super
risk you're correct this G5 idea it was
clear what his intentions were he needed
play for a win so he decided to strike
early but his King is in the center
White's King is tucked away and look at
this bishop B5 black has to Castle Queen
side if you don't Castle Queen side the
game is just over as white will pile up
pressure on the pin Knight on D7 very
quickly so cast and queen side when
you've already rided yourself of the fan
ketto light squore Bishop o too many
holes to speak of the White Queen can
jump into E4 the only thing and I really
mean the only thing that black has quote
unquote going for him is that the E5
Pawn is tender and so if you can't
defend that pawn adequately maybe black
steals it but even if black were to win
that pawn I would still like White's
chances because the black king will
never ever be safe this looks bad it is
bad but Jan had to do
something I'm just surprised he
hesitated so long before castling quid
side that was as you say Robert the only
move the only way to justify what he'd
previously done and okay J that Jose uh
did look up did shake his head maybe he
just forgot that that was a legal move
it's easy to forget in chess especially
in such a weak flank vulnerable squares
all around especially on the light
squares um but now he does need to uh
kind of deliver Checkmate or somehow
keep an attack going because as you
mentioned as well this Pawn is going to
drop if black gets one or two more moves
if black gets Knight to E7 maybe Knight
to G6 and just takes this Pawn
everything's possible anything's
possible if white doesn't deliver
Checkmate so yes it's a bad position for
black yes we see the evaluation bar but
at least now he's kind of narrowed the
path he said yes the stakes are high
Checkmate me if you do you deserve to
win this match and progress in the
winners bracket if not I'll win your
pawn and I'm back in it so uh
interesting strategy Mind Games here
from
Nomi and it's a really fascinating
position right because we're talking
about white needing to find a way to
actually win as quickly but I was just
about to point out that can white play a
slow move like A4 because there's this
really fun line that can happen if black
was to go G4 you know E5 Pawn is the big
weakness in in the position and he
doesn't and David I just wanted to
highlight that it could be because of
the move Queen to E4 and I don't know if
the tactics work out but the evalar
doesn't move so it seems like it does
and the point is after F3 and I'm going
to ask you to help me do I give a check
on A8 or do I go further with a
sacrifice Rook takes Knight is so
tempting and I think it does work
because after Rook D7 Rook D7 Queen to
A8 you give a check now only move Queen
B8 I pick up the Rook on
D7 and it should be game over should be
game over of course it never dies always
continues but uh yeah the black king now
has to defend its Queen and here I'm
assuming that there are going to be
checkmating patterns if you just move
the bishop out the way you could
probably even throw it away and then
with a check bring the Rook into the
center this looks over love it Tanya and
watch out for that type of thing to kind
of consistently pop up that type of
pattern let's go back to the game uh
after Knight to E7 A5 he's trying to
just blow open the queen side and I
think he's keeping this trick up his
sleeve
like you said he's trying to wait for
the black pawn to go to G4 then Queen E4
is pretty much a double attack so A5
he's playing really energetically here
Jose but he still needs to deliver the
killer blow and uh I think npish he's
doing the right thing he said a he's
cast with queenside now he is just has
to take the material take this Pawn if
he can and just pray that there's no
Checkmate no knockout blow um four and a
half minutes for Jose Robert do you
think he's going to find something how
easy is it to find something here for
white not not easy at all Ian you just
said Yan said a then he says ba I will
take your Pawn thank you so much for it
and that also frees the B6 square up for
a black knight if you need help
defending the Knight on E7 May jump into
the D5 Square as well so I actually
believe that this position it's hard to
prove for white as a you know an
audience member as a spectator as a
commentator you look you say the
evaluation bar is really high up there
White's in charge the king is safe on G1
that black king on C8 it looks like
there's a lot of air in front of it but
the E5 Pawn that is is a long-term
weakness it's overextended and I don't
see an easy way to defend it so white
needs to give up that pawn and go for an
attack but if you start rushing for your
attack let's say you play the move Pawn
to B4 just try to really blast open that
side of the board you have to make sure
that you will have the knockout and
actually somehow that move is Justified
the engine doesn't mind it but I I I was
trying to make the point that like you
could just really be onedimensional
tunneled on the attack and you may drop
all of your other Pawns in the center
but I guess be is real and it's because
the black king is unsafe so I was just
trying to give a throwaway move and yet
that's how good White's position is at
the moment but I still truly believe
that it could go wrong if you're not
careful and uh there we see uh just
below the board right now actually Nishi
has played two moves that have been
given a question mark but it's because
of the match situation is and uh yes
he's technically objectively made the
position worse but he's made it harder
for Jose Martinez to navigate these
choppy Waters and uh okay one more move
a couple more moves have been played
Bishop takes suddenly things are
balancing out a question mark from Jose
trading off pieces and uh is this making
his job easier in terms of guiding it
towards safety going for the draw what
is his plan here he gives a check and uh
after the Black Knight blocks some more
quick moves by the players this one's
really calmed down but black is still
temporarily at least a pawn up another
Pawn will drop I think the pomnish is
surviving this game but he needs to win
um
what do you think of these
developments I think the only way to
explain it is the Matt situation for Jos
bam a draw is what he needs to wrap it
up and he doesn't want to complicate to
the things doesn't want to complicate
things too much but that said he's
giving Yana pishi the chances that he
needs I think josam have to keep the
pressure going right now the big
question is he can't pick up the A5 Pawn
The Rook from A1 can slide on to D1 you
give a check but black skin can simply
fall back to see it it's one check how
are you continuing this in initiative
how you continuing the attack the one
idea I want to point out before I pass
the ball to you Robert to break it down
further is that White's Queen can
actually also think about infiltrating
from the other side of the board always
watch out from a future perspective the
queen landing on e4 or on C2 and
actually going into the 8 seven square
to start targeting the pawns on the
Queen's side still a lot to fight for
for white but I feel he's made life a
bit easier for Yan Robert I love that
point about the White Queen it looks
well positioned but it looks even better
on a sore like H7 white could actually
strike this H6 G5 Pawn chain with a move
like H4 at some point but what I really
love the most is Jose's last move Knight
to D2 he's losing contact with the E5
Pawn but he is trying to improve the
location of his Knight that piece wasn't
doing much of anything on F3 he's giving
up a pawn because that A5 Pawn Knight C4
Knight takes A5 that looks available and
wow I think that Yan had to take he is
trying to liquidate a little bit because
if that Knight does leave C4 now after
the trade on A5 maybe B2 is loose but
you need to be really really careful
with this pin along the diagonal Rook D1
check coming your way white could win a
piece if Black's not careful and I don't
think there's enough material left for
Yan to have realistic winning chances so
I think Jose is doing everything right I
just want to point out one trick you
cannot take this Knight it's given a
question mark this move it wasn't the
best butth just if we go back one move
Queen takes Knight would have been a
losing blunder not because of Queen
takes Queen but because of a check the
queen jumps out the way with a check and
a discovered attack against the black
queen then The Queen Is Lost next move
so Yan playing correctly Bishop to D6
blocking any he checks against his King
and he lives to fight another day but uh
okay he keeps the Queens on now sh Pam
and still with great chances of
potentially punishing Yan pomi for being
greedy black living life on the edge and
wow I was going to say let's zoom out
but suddenly a blunder attached to this
last
move wa suddenly winning the evaluation
bar has gone Sky High but what is The
Knockout blow Knight takes Bishop
removing a Defender perhaps the black
queen is simply going to be kicked off
balance right now actually Black's
pieces fall like Domino's next move the
Rook comes no matter which piece you
take with and let's just show this the
queen is overworked she has to defend
her Knight she has to defend the pawn
but she's attacked and if she gives way
for example drops back to C7 then a
simple capture a check and a knock
skewer to end
winning he's about to take this Victory
luckily the White Queen protects her
Rook as well so no back rank checkm
tricks let's go back to the game
position Jos bam is about to take this
Victory we saw Yan pom Nishi just smile
again shake his head nothing to do this
was a disastrous
move hii knows that this is over and we
could see it on him he's fed he's Frozen
Robert it's like Jose has used the
freezing spell on Yan right now with
that last move the C5 Pawn is about to
fall everything's falling apart moral of
the story do not keep your king in the
center and play G6 to G5 it invited too
much long-term trouble for Yan and he
knows that his Road in the F in the
Winner's bracket comes to a stop it is
double elimination so there's still hope
for Yan pishi well I thought you were
going to say the moral of the story is
that David spell is better than mine
because I said tornado and that's what
Yana pomi did in this game and then you
said Jam uses freeze and it seems like
yandi has made his move no longer Frozen
but Rook D1 check Bishop takes C5 coming
it just seems like material will be one
for the white side and all he needs is a
draw so he doesn't need to win this game
if he can force a draw at any moment he
should do just that so josam you could
see him he was bopping his head he's
feeling the Rhythm he's winning this
match this wins King this wins King of
the Hill but not usually chess
games oh
my favorite variant Robert where you win
if you get your king to one of these
four Central squares quicker than the
opponent but yeah normally in real chest
you get checkmated and uh do not take
this Pawn right now you will get M on
the spot the White Queen will recapture
on F4 and the black king would be
trapped so you have to flee you have to
run King to F5 but surely there's going
to be a knockout blow in the near future
a check maybe we'll see your idea Tanya
that you predicted miles in the future
uh you could check come into H7 this
black king get uh trapped within the
next few moves surely no way you survive
out in the open like this he's just
taken on G5 and once a black captures
recaptures on G5 then all these ideas
come into play you could start with Rook
to F1 eventually the queen can come to
E4 as well if Black's King Falls to G6
this king is not going to survive in the
center of this hill at all and Yan pishi
he's just thinking does he even play on
in this position and if so what is going
to be his next move cuz it looks like it
might be his L one the king is dying on
that Hill it's not getting anywhere it
can Retreat to G6 at some point but C5
can fall and I think the attack is very
clear so yanami he hasn't made his move
I think he understands that this match
is his opponents and so he just maybe
just prolonging the inevitable at this
point as it's going to be a match
victory for Jose Martinez the Peruvian
star proving once again that he can
handle even the best players in the
world in these uh short matches
not that many games don't count him out
ever he is really
exceptional it so good in these formats
yeah just incredible play right even in
this game he needed only a draw but then
he goes He seizes the opportunity to go
E5 blows open the queen side after the
castle with A4 A5 really nicely played
attack and now he's putting the
finishing touches to the game so Black's
King on E5 is actually just trapped
there it's got no SC squares all you
need is to deliver one check where is
that check coming from can you just fall
back with the bishop to F2 and going
Bishop G3 goes Queen F2 another idea and
that's it Yan she
resigns Jose Martinez is on a roll he
gets the job done in the winners
quarterfinals he puts Yan pishi in the
losers bracket what a day of Chess it's
been for him what a match it's been
taking the first game and the final game
wrapping it up he did not need to go
into the Armageddon fantastic play and
he stays in the Winner's
bracket in the meantime though we do
have other games Ono let's uh jump over
to see okay it's just finished the other
man in the must-win situation was Wesley
so but ultimately wasn't successful a
draw just agreed by repetition Magnus
Carlson progressing in that one um so
Wesley tried tried 57 moves but it
wasn't enough mag shutting the door on
any potential comeback so we have two
players progressing lazic against Vash
gra on the far left we haven't covered
much but we will get to cover due to
that Armageddon incoming and that leaves
fua against fed and we know all about
those two fighters evaluation but on wh
side in the remaining game but looks
like a mess looks complicated um a quick
count shows though Robert that white is
a porn up how easy do you think this is
to convert for FIA
uh not easy at all and I couldn't even
count the material I thought for a
second someone was an exchange up but
that's because there's a white Rook on
A6 like it's out in the wilderness but
it's also keeping Black's pieces at Bay
uh the G5 Pawn sticks out Whit's Knights
they're both towards the rim but they're
putting immediate pressure on the C5
Pawn which cannot be captured right away
because the Rook on E1 is loose so there
are a lot of tactics and handing black a
pass Pawn that would seem scary to me
but it looks like fua he has everything
under control the engine agrees with his
choice it looks like black is about to
lose a pawn in this position David you
fall back with the Knight white trades
the rook and you'll either end up losing
the C6
Pawn saying that is Knight C3 the idea
behind this move is f have going to go
in with that Knight further on the board
I think you called it Tanya you have to
just uh be ambitious here you cannot
Retreat as soon as you start retreating
things will not go your way you lose
momentum so jumping in with the Knight
hoping to uh kind of recapture on C3 and
create this monstrous pass Pawn um I was
going to say really nice simplification
here by fuia making the equation easier
to work out but suddenly Knight C5 that
was flashy the white Rook on E1 was
undefended so there was a trade and he
gets back with his Knight but uh is
flashy necessarily good this Pawn will
be blocked by White Knight on the D2
Square so Black's big Ace up his sleeve
is the D Pawn suddenly it's not so clear
the black Rook might come in watch out
for the white king no Defenders around
it and the evaluation bar
sliding wow could we see a turnar around
wh's two pawns up but Black's pieces are
so active yeah I think you could push
this Pawn to D3 to force the White
Knight back and now Rook E8 because Rook
e 2 is a Tempo shot oh Rook B8 similar
idea but the engine doesn't seem to love
it so it's given a question mark maybe
it's because ah the Knight drops back
blocking the file and protecting the
other Knight now it's a Tempo too slow
so I think David that was a missed
opportunity from FV and now look at fua
has everything under
controling through he's going to win
this G pawn and from the G5 Square
whites Rook does a sterling job of
Defending its own Pawn on G2 now white
is three whole pawns to the good and uh
this Pawn is held under lock and key
Black's D Pawn so close to touchdown but
not close enough the white Knights do a
great job of Defending each other and
blockading knights are the best
blockaders and now Loose as well it's
all gone wrong for FV after we joined it
he had such good compensation
fja though fantastic technique and it
feels like he's just putting the
finishing touches on now the white pawns
will start marching as long as you don't
get checkmated you're winning this
game p to C5 7 Seconds against 22 how
big a factor do we think is the
clock that's his only hope for fedos he
has to try to keep the pressure on try
to find tricks with the Knight and the
Rook combined alira fuja marches up with
his own King delivering a check the C
Pawn can move forward now also defending
the Rook he back allowing a pawn capture
on G2 coming in with a check so some
counterplay going on here The Rook can
go to E5 now there are all kinds of
checks happening on the board this might
not be over yet and no look at the
evaluation bar it's now even because
that white king it's hiding Behind Enemy
Lines It Might Get checkmated Behind
Enemy Lines so watch out for Knight E6
check Knight H5 check I think right now
you can continue maneuvering this night
around but white is two pawns ahead so
if there is no Checkmate you need to be
careful so I guess fed just stealing
Pawns in the process David do you
actually think that black could be the
side for Choice definitely and look how
focused fed is right now he senses an
opportunity the white king just marched
too far in again King of the Hill active
Kings you got to be really careful about
and suddenly Black's promoting this Pawn
black is pushing you have to be really
careful White's going for checkmate
suddenly who's who's winning this race
it's a pure Race White can he give Petr
check if not black promotes and wins
Rook to D7 a blunder black deflects the
rook and wins a new Queen SK to appear
oh my gosh what a find by fedos Sav and
he wins the game is over fedos Sav takes
it what a defensive F by him what a Miss
by Ala fuja Rook to F7 the big resource
the Big Move by the big fish and that
gets him back in the match as he wins
his fourth game game leveling the score
alira fuja so close this is a
heartbreaking moment for alira and he's
got to fight it out now in the
Armageddon oh ala fua actually goes down
to the losers bracket uh what a game
that was just letting it slip from the
uh from the brink of Victory there three
points to the good fed what a comeback
and uh yeah we also see the other
results there Tanya um so many twist
turns in this first day of
quarterfinals yeah we saw right Robert
sorry Robert just wanted to correct
myself that ala fuja actually from
winning the match now loses and goes
down to the losers bracket as you
pointed out but we do have one
Armageddon coming up we do just Dennis
laik against Maxim Vash four draws that
was a very even match the other ones
Topsy Turvy Magnus had things under
control after his win but between FV and
fua it seemed like that match could have
gone anyone's way but the last mistake
is the critical one and Ali Raza fuja he
goes down to the losers bracket fed
remains in the winners as does Jose
Martinez maybe the most impressive
performer in the
quarterfinals and uh I just wanted to
highlight that moment and do a bit of a
deep dive into where it all went wrong
for alera fuja he'd already let the
advantage slip he had a three-point
Advantage but now the white king simply
getting chased to its Doom uh we saw the
white king now step even further into
the enemy camp he should have run to
safety supporting his own pawns run to
the queen side that was the only way to
keep this game under control instead he
marched forward and a few moves later we
already saw white find the only move to
avoid Checkmate Knight E6 is a
checkmating pattern the white king uh
would have been doomed here but if we
fast forward the next few moves we saw a
few twists and turns a few checks here
and there but it was now once the
blockader of this black dwn disappeared
that fuja uh lost even more control he
went for a Counterattack against the
black king but ultimately missing in
this position the only way to draw it
was difficult he could have given a KN
check and if black wants to win then
King to A7 the only move and uh here you
can give a few checks but more
importantly you can play Rook to D7
x-ray vision defending this square if
black makes a new Queen you check and
you win this queen next if however
instead black tries the same trick Rook
to F7 deflection as we soon see in the
game then the White Knight is within
touching distance of guarding this
Square actually maybe first uh a bit of
a finesse here maybe you need to
actually just move the white king out
the way the Rook still protected instead
he missed this very difficult undertime
pressure under duress Rook to D7 instead
and beautiful double exclamation mark
deflection simply the white Rook
disappears no Guardian no bodyguard of
the black d Point anymore black makes a
new Queen and fed sa won the
quarterfinal wow so sharp by fed sa
right there and and Ali RZA fuja he took
the lead in the match but it's FV who
advances in the winnner bracket we've
got a big armagon coming up between
Maxim vher lra and Dennis lazic as the
players fight to get to the top of the
chable Masters but don't go anywhere in
the break because during the break for
all of you we've got a special video
coming up with Kristoff SE sel's
impressive rise to the top don't go
anywhere
[Music]
I used to work at the bank from 7 to 6 I
was a stock market analyst I always had
an interest in this working on a time
pressure and at that time I had a friend
it was Kristoff seli who was also
working at the bank during our lunch
times we often walked through the park
and and played chess as well I thought
one time well Kristoph you're you're so
good in explaining all this stuff why
don't you just record it you know make
make a video or something and maybe
other people can can listen to it as
well yeah and it all started from there
at the time I found YouTube which was
pretty new in 2011 and I uploaded my
first video on my chess explained
Channel and it was funny because I sent
Mich the video links so that he could
watch and give me feedback but all of a
sudden dozens of people
[Music]
watched later on when the channel chel
was larger I got plenty of people
contacting me about lessons and then I
started
teaching yeah so the the channel was
really kind of the the beginning of
thinking about Chess as a career and I
quickly had a a full schedule like
basically teaching 30 hours a
week chess is such a beautiful and and
kind of multifaceted game and you find
something new every day in chess
openings in particular Which is my my
forte I'm thrilled to find new ideas
present them to the audience and and
help them to play a better and
entertaining
chess totally fascinating if you talk
with Kristoff about Chess in general but
also specially openings he's like a
machine a Fountain of
Knowledge I I was always fascinated by
the opening phase of the game because I
think due to this fixed starting
position you have something
very um it's very explorable you have a
very constant thing that you can look
at yeah I think my my total highlight of
my career with with with chess and with
with chessel um that happened in 20120
when pretty much out of the blue I got
this offer to work together with Peter
hin and Ne and Magnus Caron's Chief
trainer and second to write a course
about Magnus called the Magnus touch
about Magnus great ability in end games
in Middle games planning like all his
best games and ideas and I wrote that
together with Peter H was a great
experience we were on yeah plenty of
Zoom calls that was in the height of the
pandemic it's pretty pretty
wild at the end Magnus recorded the
whole thing yeah based on my my script
which was
fascinating a real great experience to
get in touch with like the highest level
of Chess which was completely
unimaginable before I never thought that
something like that could
happen it's just a a wild journey in a
way uploading a video in July 2011 and
from going there to their cooperation
with with Camp Magnus and then finally
last year in 2022 I won this author of
the year for chessel after having
successful courses in the past couple of
years it was just like impossible to
imagine when I just started doing like a
single video for my friend basically and
then at the end this whole thing
transpired it's it's really
[Music]
unbelievable
oh
[Music]
welcome to the most exciting format in
chess
Armageddon the ultimate tiebreaker
Armageddon grants white more time on the
clock but in return white must must win
a draw secures black the match win white
starts with 10 minutes and each player
submits a confidential bid with an
amount of time they are willing to start
with Lois bid gets to choose their color
usually black in those coveted draw ODS
let the Armageddon
[Music]
commence
it's the most destructive format in Chaz
and it's aply called the Armageddon and
the bids are in by the players and look
at that Dennis lawick out bit outsmarts
Maxim Vash lrab by three seconds Dennis
lawick wins the Armageddon bid 6 minutes
to 40 seconds Maxim VRA bit 6 minutes to
43 seconds David what do you make of
this bid has Dennis lovic managed to get
into Maxine's head
it does certainly look that way first
off uh we should mention it's a
different format last season they had 15
minutes base time this year it's going
to be even faster uh but it definitely
feels like Dennis full of confidence
having avoided defeat in regular time
today those four games he was never
really in trouble he's backing himself
here to draw with black who cares if
it's a few extra minutes for the
opponent and uh I love that attitude um
as you say Tanya it feels like pressures
definitely on Vash gra now needing win
with white needing to find something a
bit different from uh the games earlier
today and Robert it's a similar story
line to the Champions Chester finals in
Toronto in the round robin stages where
Dennis lazic Maxim VRA playing against
each other two draws and finally Dennis
took the win in the Armageddon there he
had the white pieces is this something
that's going on in the players Minds
right now what happened just two months
ago I must play in their minds because
Maxim VRA that was a disappointing
result for him in an underwhelming
performance so for maxim he wants to get
the job done here but Dennis he is shown
that why should he lose any game even
against the super Grand Masters he beat
Hikaru two to nothing he then took down
Anish giri now he's going toe totoe
every bit Maxim's equal in this specific
match so there is limited time on his
clock but he's shown that his moves they
are great and even under the duress of
time trouble he has proven in his bullet
chest prowess that he can handle it yeah
and this is the first time we've got the
base time as 10 minutes in the Champions
Chester what do you think about those
Dynamics starting with 6 minutes and 40
seconds has Dennis laic is this bit too
low the games are off what do you think
about 6 minutes 40 seconds before we get
into the
opening we're going to find out Tanya
this is one of the first times this
season we've seen this type of dynamic
and um yeah six minutes it might not
sound like much but the top players they
play bullet games all the time Dennis
lavic so experienced and look at this
Central mess all the tension there
temporarily all the knights were staring
off at each other in the middle of the
board suddenly they all disappear in the
blink of an eye and still a three and a
half minute time Advantage for Vash gra
so this is a branch of the English
opening earlier uh in their clashes in
regular time we saw the Spanish the
Berlin lots of really KY slow sty stuff
now bash gra going direct this Central
strategy and uh he's got a hope that he
can
esic off guard Robert who are you
favoring it's early days but who do you
think is going to be happy with the
outcome of the opening well the
evaluation bar the engine to the left
hand side of the board is happy with
Black's play but I think that Maxim he
should also be happy because this isn't
a symmetrical Pawn structure white has
two Central pawns the D and the E pawns
black has only one and I do love
Dennis's last move Queen F6 he does not
want to give white the entire Center if
there is a trade on D4 then it's two
versus zero in the center but black has
an extra two pawns on the queen side so
this is what we're going to be talking
about that's the Dynamics of this
position is that the pawn structure is
not the same for each side they're
playing for different
ideas and before the game started we
were talking about the matchup in
Toronto which was a wild back but
perhaps Maxim is also thinking about
what happened yesterday Dennis laic took
down Anish giri in an Armageddon in a
very convincing manner gave no chances
at all and I think if I memory says me
right that is was black in that game it
ended in a draw and thenis took the
match he made it look easy and right now
I do like the fact that the pieces the
minor pieces it's all symmetrical right
now yes the pawn structure it does
provide some play for Maxine but to me
it looks like it's not going to be
enough it's just a position that's easy
to play and with black you just need a
draw to win the
Armageddon and as you can see that
experience you can tell that he's played
a bunch of Armageddon just the way he's
handling it he still spent less than one
minute on on the clock to get this far
into the game we're at move 20 now
Bishops disappear as well he's getting
closer to safety and okay he makes this
controversial decision though that
Robert highlighted earlier he's allowing
bashra to just take this Pawn off the
board and I think correctly taking with
the pawn towards the center yes Black's
pieces are active the queen The Rook on
the open file the white Bishop is a bit
stuck on the E3 square but ultimately
now uh even if the Queens disappear
Rooks disappear Bishops off the board
there is this imbalance long term so um
I like what Dennis is doing especially
this last move throwing pawns down the
board now super quick play but Vash gra
he's got to be banking on his chances
long term and um yeah as long as he
keeps that two and a half minute two
minute time Advantage I think it might
come down to a scramble uh as you said
Tanya a draw is enough for Dennis but
still a while to go before that Queen's
coming off the board as well wow
surprising decision Rob I love the way
that both of these two are playing
because Queen B5 had a hidden threat
that if the black queen didn't Escape
there was a bishop G5 with a skewer so
now the Queens are off the board that
should make it easier for white to push
the pawns if this E2 Pawn were on e4
then we'd start feeling a little bit
more confident about White's chances but
look at Dennis his last move Rook to E7
it's clear he wants to double Rooks and
prevent white from pushing forward in
the center but now he's also pressing
forward himself on the king side these
are players who are playing on both
sides of the board they're not just
tunneled in the center I think that
black is stable the question now becomes
can white make any inroads Tanya do you
see anything here that would lead you to
believe that white can in fact make
progress I don't know about White's
progress but the last few moves by
Dennis Robert to me it seems he's the
one who's looking for Progress he's
expanded on the king side he wants to
make the move H5 to H4 next try and open
up the hline looking for chances of The
Rook infiltrating with Rook H1 maybe
trading off more pieces on the board in
general when it's the Armageddon when
you're fighting for a draw when you're
low on the the clock with black having
managed to trade off so many pieces I
think so far it's been s success for
Dennis
lazic been a lazza victory this last few
moves at least in terms of the
psychological battle Black's King as
well has a clear path towards the center
just blocked off and wow Dennis creating
threats along the background but watch
out for White's threat white is now
threatening in the near future to take
this Pawn on B6 and undermine the black
Bishop on D6 hence White's protected and
uh yeah I was thinking about what pieces
need to disappear I think white wouldn't
mind the Bishops disappearing being
traded off and uh black would love the
Rooks to disappear because then the B
Pawn will run so still very very tense
both sides with a lot to play for but
I'm looking at the clock still five
minutes Dennis is so Speedy uh just
another level so quick here he's making
Armageddon look uh like a classical game
he's just enjoying this moment and he's
playing against Max V the 2021 bu bless
Champion one of the biggest spee chess
Specialists of modern chess and he just
keeps the game going and the clock under
control I have to ask robt Robert a
question here is F5 ever a move you want
to make in these positions to try to get
rid of as many pawns on the board it
absolutely is a move that will be
justified and is a good decision from a
practical standpoint does it create some
risk I think the answer is also yes so
F5 I love it I think the engine will
approve but for lazic does he need to do
anything unlike spell chess he can just
sit here and just kind of hang out right
you know he doesn't have to use freeze
he doesn't have to do anything special
but he actually did just move his Bishop
in the center and that move it changed
the evaluation a little bit but black is
no worse all he needs is a draw he's
piling up on the D5 Pawn actually what
can you do as white isn't that pawn just
dropping this might spell the end
talking of spells it might spell the end
for Vash gra in the Winner's bracket
he's trying to desperately trade off
Bishops now but Dennis I think you'll
sport for choice just get rid of this
bishop take this Pawn off the board if
you want to be flashy you could have
taken the pawn as well that would have
led some tactics now all he needs to do
just trade off one set of Rooks even if
Black's two queen side pawns disappear
with the absence of both sets of Rooks
if it's just one set left easy draw and
uh why actually worry about that when
you can go for the Counterattack Black's
a whole Pawn up and he's going to put
his Rook on F7 defend everything I think
bash grav is the one fighting for the
draw here he's having to take risks and
look at the march of these two connected
passes these two pawns together will win
the game for lazic now or at least will
get him the desired
result
Maxim is down upon he's just got a one
minute lead on the clock flagging is
nowhere in the cards right now Dennis
lazovic in driver's seat he made it look
against an easy against Anish gri he's
making it look easy against Maxim V lra
how does the kid do it Robert
he's a fantastic player he's just
extremely underrated and the top players
they don't take him lightly and we just
saw him beat Hikaru and Anan he is not
losing this game to Maxim Vash lra all
Dennis needs is a draw he may in fact
win this game as Maxim has to go all out
uh this question mark I don't care about
it I think we can all agree to disagree
with the game review saying that yeah
maybe it's not the objective best move
but all black needs is a draw so to
answer your question Tanya is that
Dennis is underrated he's a great player
he's exceptional speed chess player and
he can do it in Rapid even in the world
rapid championships he's shown that so
credit to him he is just an amazing
amazing player at just
so I wanted to say he has a superpower
and he knows how to use it he has a low
rating and this is for everyone out
there at home if you're playing someone
higher rated you can just play solid you
can bully them and uh use it against
them and there wece resignation Dennis
wins it and gets past Maxi V gr
17-year-old Dennis lazic he gets the job
done in the Armageddon against Maxim VRA
takes the dub stays in the Winner's
bracket goes through to the winner
semi-final he relegated Hikaru Nakamura
he relegated Anish G and now he puts
Maxim basher lrav in the losers bracket
incredible Chess By Dennis he really is
a menace to the top
guys he is indeed that's why we call it
is a loving nickname for him but he is a
menace and he will be for years to come
because Dennis lazic he continues to
prove why he made it through to the
Champions chestor finals just two months
ago now in Toronto is just he can hang
with the best players he doesn't win
that many games let's be clear but he
can hang he can draw and when all you
need is a draw with the black pieces
against the super Grand Master he can do
it and he just
did that was absolute class by Dennis
and David it just felt like Maxim never
got a chance what was the highlight for
you in this impressive
Armageddon simply Dennis was in control
from move one I wanted to highlight one
moment where the maturity of Dennis
lazic play really sha through and uh
this is our game review uh we'll see
some exclamation marks we'll see some
question marks but remember Dennis
doesn't have to play the best moves he
just has to play the safest moves with a
draw being sufficient so Rook to D7 here
attacking White's Central Pawn and after
this tricky move Bishop to D4 Dennis did
not get PA he did not get tempted to
take this Pawn allowing some
complications here no doubt bash gra
would have actually given up material
sacrific The Exchange but suddenly black
loses control suddenly yes it's Bishop
for Rook should favor black but white
has three connected pawns here and
actually white would have chances long
term this Pawn would drop in the near
future the black king not entirely safe
and suddenly white would uh open things
up to having three possible results um
so instead let's go back and see what he
did he actually just traded off the
Bishops first removing all risk and yes
this comes at the cost of a potential
extra Pawn but if White had taken this
Rook off the board we would have seen an
easily drawable end game Dennis lazic
again not to be underestimated he knows
exactly how the end games work he knows
what to aim for and ultimately he's a
hard man to beat and that got him
through this
match we've been talking about Dennis's
style one of his biggest Trends has been
his game play we saw it an against Anish
we saw it today against Max IM we're
going to go into a Shar break but don't
go anywhere as we're going to be joined
by Dennis who just took down Maxim in
this thrilling battle we'll be back with
the winner of that match in just a
[Music]
few
man
hello V come V come so this is where the
magic happen happens and this is where
all the magic is already happened yes
that's a good way of putting it that's
my world junior I 87 it's difficult to
tell you how many doors that opened for
me and what uh what historical moment it
was and when I got back the chess
Oscars very nice these five of them of
the W five and there's one on top that
is the sixth one so since he had already
got five they didn't want to give him
the same trophy so they gave him a
trophy of a king with the world in his
hand this is anand's first ever
mentioned in a newspaper oh so this is
his first ever he was mentioned V Anand
achieved a national record by winning
all the nine rounds to notch a maximum
of nine points in the sub junior
Championship but imagine now TS ri's
daughter AK is part of the West Brian
chess Academy I mean it's so beautiful
to see how you know life comes around so
World rapid chess and mind Champion so
this was nit gave me this nice prob why
do I get that ARA knows all the trophies
and where you want better than you
remember it cuz I cleaned the because
it's true because it's
true did you have a favorite thank you
so much Anand I feel this is extra
motivation for all the youngsters this
opportunity to actually come here and
witness these achievements and spend
time with you in this stunning room
Anand Aruna thank you so much for
[Music]
this
a
which one's
you the pawn I like the
pawn the Knight the Knight can jump over
pieces
oh you want me to say the Queen the
Queen's the strongest piece on the board
this one's
you King The King sucks he can only move
one square you've got to reassess your
chest Grandmaster morrice Ashley
presents Jeremy Silman how to reassess
your chess now on chessable so go to
chess.com
yourest and start reassessing your chess
today
[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
welcome back everyone we are being
joined by the boy of the moment I should
say right now Dennis lack after his big
win against Maxim VRA taking the match
in the Armageddon firstly a big big
congratulations uh Dennis on that match
it's been awesome to watch you in the
tour last year it was awesome to watch
you in the world rapid and Blitz as well
and now it's been awesome to watch you
these last two days Dennis you've taken
down Anish giri hiar Nakamura and today
Maxim
VRA how are you feeling right now and
which one of these three has been the
most special win for
you yeah yes of course I I feel great of
course
to I mean every win was really special
for me because it's it's really hard
to to beat you know any top
players but yeah
after my my win against hikaro I I mean
I I got some additional strength
probably my confidence is improved a
little bit and then
I it was a little bit easy for me to to
play
I and Dennis you said during the
Champions chess tour finals in Toronto
that you felt it was easier for you to
play online but you know I right after
that event you went to the world rapid
in the world Blitz and once again had a
tremendous performance so uh you know
how do you keep doing it do you just
think you prefer quicker time controls
to classical chess what's your favorite
time control to
play
actually I think my my favorite control
is rapid I guess
because you know I think I a little bit
better play in Rapid but uh yeah
for in over the board chest
I in World rapid and blit I I played
better in blit
and online I I played better in in Rapid
I think
because you know when I played title
Tuesday
I sometimes I played not
so not so great but
now in Rapid I I think
I I played quite quite
good
and uh Dennis after today's Victory uh
you progress to the winner semi-final
and tomorrow it looks like you'll play
against Jose Martinez uh another inform
player what do you uh predict for that
one how do you feel about your chances
in that
match
he I I think it uh it will be more or
less equal match I I didn't play the
play against him a lot we played some
probably one rapid games and some bullet
match
which which he won but I mean it's of
course it completely completely
different yeah I think
it's more or less more or less equal
match tennis we're really looking
forward to the fight in the winnner
semifinals and you met mentioned that
winning against Hikaru gave you a lot of
confidence going ahead and we've got an
interesting chat question around that
it's by yes Senpai and he wants to know
that when you're playing against such
experienced opponents how do you manage
to stay so
calm
I I already have some experience also
so all this uh
event last year um it helped it helped
me so I mean
I I just Tred to focus somehow
I online I already played quite a lot
against top players
so I mean
I probably
I you know just
um
somehow I I do it I I cannot explain it
but yeah I I'm a professional chess
player so I I should do it
somehow that Dennis it's funny I think
that makes perfect sense sometimes we
can't explain why things happen but you
know your pieces do all the talking and
we do have another chat question from
Indiana Rahul and uh they ask Dennis how
did you choose your Armageddon time
because you were so precise you did win
the Armageddon by just three seconds so
how did you decide on the time that you
bid um when I played against Anish I I
mean there is
a tournament in
Stanger
where where they they playing armagedon
also and
the time is
like 7 and 10 I think and so it it feels
quite natural to to beat 7 minutes so I
think
he he
probably um wanted to play with black
and he probably thought that I I will
beat like 7 minutes that's why
I I beat 650
and now when I played against mvl I I
thought also
he he wanted to play with black and he
will
choose less
than
650 so I I decided to choose six 6 and
14 I because also I I wanted to play
with
black
and uh Dennis uh you're quickly becoming
one of my chess Idols but we have a
question from the chat from Jeremy Q who
is your chess Idol who's your hero in
chess I mean
I I don't I don't have
any I mean I uh I like to watch some
some games of some top players in in
past and now but uh
yeah I don't have any Idol or
something well Dennis you may not have
an idol in chest but I see you probably
have a a good friend beside you is your
cat over there your little koska is is
your cat over
there um my my cat is sleeping in in
other room
[Laughter]
so well d as you said you don't have any
Idols or Heroes but you're definitely
taking them down one by one uh in these
events and before I let you go I have to
ask you all these medals behind you so
many of them Dennis and I'm assuming
that it's all from chess tournaments um
I can't count from here but it's a lot
any any special medal amongst those
behind
you
I I cannot choose any
I mean any medal so
it's it's like my my history so every
medal is important for me of
course that is a very deep answer Dennis
uh but also just like your chess very
deep thank you so much and
congratulations thanks for giving us
your time and tomorrow you've got a big
one coming up against uh Jose Martinez
in the winner semi-finals we wish you
all the best
thank you very much thank
you see you
Dennis 17y old danis lazic with a bit of
history behind him with all those medals
he's just starting to make his legacy in
the Chess World well it's been quite a
performance for him in the last two days
taking down three of the world's best
players but the action continues as we
see on our bracket here in the winner
semi-final Dennis will take on Jose
Martinez mag Carlson will take on
Vladimir FV Robert two big matchups
coming up in the semi-finals what's your
take on this action well we also have
matches going on in the losers bracket
but you asked me what happens up top so
I'll keep my head up high and I think
that between Magnus Carlson and Vladimir
fedos we'll have players swinging at one
another and then of course between
Dennis lavic and Jose Martinez we have a
bit of a stylistic clash but they both
are quite solid in nature and they love
to get down to their waning second so uh
in the winners bracket it will be
interesting chest for sure and the
losers bracket it's a fight to survival
so David I don't know which match is
your favorite because all these feature
are some excellent very fan favorite
players now we're really spoiled for
choice in the losers bracket where the
states are higher than ever they cannot
afford any more match defeats um I'm
going to say npom nesi fash gra is going
to be fire on the board npom nesi we saw
it today not quite clicking into gear
but I have a feeling tomorrow he'll be
desperate to make a men so a lot to look
forward
to I'm really excited about that one as
well David both players disappointed
with day one here in division one we're
going to see an angry Yan and an angry
Maxim Vash lra both on their lost lives
of course there are big matchups all
around in the winners bracket as well
it's been awesome it's been amazing
covering a division one with both of you
once again and if of course chat we will
be back with day two with the winners
semifinals as well as the losers bracket
as two players will be knocked out off
Division One tomorrow it's a goodbye
from the three of us we'll see you
[Music]
tomorrow
a
n
[Music]
oh